Thank you. The meeting has now ended.
You are the only participant in the meeting.
270. 270.
And so we fall within the numbers that is identified
in the agreement. What you see in the upper left there, it says Future Plat
C. That was originally going to be part of this phase. Ivory Homes has pulled
that out. That will likely be some townhomes, but they pulled that out. They're redesigning
some things on that. So that will come in again, come back to you for
concept level review. at a future date. The park you see in the
center there, if you recall the agreements, the agreement
over the years has been modified, mostly related to park
construction. So now the park in Village 2 has to be constructed before
the 400th dwelling is platted. So that will then occur in this phase.
Just some trail connections, that sort of thing here.
Again, park. This is just— the blue and red were my
check, my looking at nodes and links to make sure they
meet the nodes and links, which they do.
Landscape plan along the units, the single-family homes.
These are all single-family homes. Just the park strip landscape
plan you see here. And that is
the concept plan right there. Thank you. Any questions for staff
or for the applicant?
So the traffic study that was in the packet, I believe, was from
about 5 or 6 years ago. 6,
yeah. And so my question is, because as I looked through the— like the ARMDA,
looked through the development agreement, it says that every new
village needs its own traffic study.
And so it seems to me that that that this is not
compliant with that. And it seems like a new traffic study would need to be—
Yeah, I'd have to turn any traffic question over to Vince. I don't— can't
review a traffic study. Or David,
I guess. Were you here to get a context on that? So Overland
Phase 2, the most current traffic study is from 2019, or Village 2
is 2019. The ARMDA requires it every village.
Are you familiar with the current traffic
study? I'm not for that one, no. So I'll
ask a different question. Do you feel it's warranted at this point
as far as Overland, or what's, you know, help direct council on?
So we had this discussion today actually with Brad and myself.
We're wanting to see— we're not seeing enough traffic impact studies for development.
Overall as a whole. And if we are, they're old or they're outdated. We want
to see more, more recent. The city is growing so fast.
2019, you know, Pony Express was one lane.
So yeah, I think we want to see a new study. And especially taking into
account the adjacent properties, um,
would be— would be— I mean, maybe both at the same time,
or— Yeah, I would. There's probably efficiency in doing it as a region for
the area. Yeah, absolutely. Does that answer the question,
Craig, or is that— Yeah, so it seems like we need one.
And it's Section 6.4, I believe, that— if
I remember right in there. But it's— I think it's very
clear in this development agreement that there would be a traffic study for
each individual village as it gets approved. And so I think that needs to
I got lots of questions, David, and I don't know if you're the right guy,
so I'm just going to ask them. Is there purple pipe in this phase?
Excuse me? Are they putting purple pipe in this phase?
If you'd like, Brad, you maybe— maybe we're not— come to the mic in case.
Okay, so that's a no. And then I, I did have a question
maybe for you, Brad, and it's just about— obviously you've reviewed the sewer, water,
stormwater, all of that. Do you have any concerns with any of, any of what
you see there? Okay, that was one of the questions I wanted to ask.
And then the other question that I had is in 5.2 in the,
in the ARMDA, it says that the matching lot sizes in Village 2, 3,
and 7 will have single families no smaller than a half
acre or the average lot size of the immediate adjacent property.
Has that been factored into this? Yeah, to the north, there's no
approved plan right now to the north.
Okay, and then I have a question about— so does that mean that
we're going to do multifamily against that border? Is that— I mean, I'm not sure
what that means. Yeah, what that's referring— I recall
the language that when the village, whatever section of the village came
in, if there's already an approved plan or even platted lots, that's where
you have to match, or I think it's a B grade or something like that,
that the language is. But there's no approved plan right now. To the north,
on the north side of 2. Okay, that was one of the things I wanted
to ask. And then, oh boy, Arnot Peak.
I want to do some arm twisting with you, Brad, on Arnot Peak. I don't
know if our traffic engineers kind of talked with you, but it's the timing of
that, especially that northern section. I know we've had at least a short
conversation about that. What are your thoughts about advancing that
timetable or building it all at the same time as we're trying to create some
ingress and egress out of Lone Tree that will connect there. Yeah,
we addressed that in the Planning Commission and we're, we're agreeable
to work with you guys on that. That's not a problem.
Excellent. With regards to traffic, so Overland
has 8 villages. This is Village 2. The traffic
study was submitted with Village 2. This is actually an amendment
to a previously approved Village 2B plan.
So this is not a new village, it's just an amendment to Plat
B of what was already approved once before. And really the only
amendment is to reposition the
townhome locations and make the lots wider so they fit more
3-car garages. This is really the only changes. The road
patterns are basically the same. So If that
helps context.
Those are my questions.
Do you think— is that going to satisfy?
Do you think we still need— No, I think that would satisfy from
what Brad just said, that it was already contemplated, the area and the density.
It's just kind of— that sounds like I'm saying just removing things around
and then— yeah, that would work for us. But I think I would add to
that, I mean, it's obvious if that's the latest traffic study, that as Village 3
comes in or the next village you bring it forward, we really— I would advocate
that we, that we, that we ask for a new updated traffic plan
for sure, or whatever study, whatever you call it, Brad.
I mean, just let's, let's just take a look at it. It's been a while
since we've looked at that and things have changed significantly, especially in that area.
One thing to note on this too, you mentioned Arnaud Peak.
The original plan that was approved had homes fronting on
that on that street. So it really was a large
street acting like a residential neighborhood street.
This plan has been amended so that all the
homes back on that, so it can act like a true collector street like
you were hoping to have it. And so that's one of the changes on this
plan. I think it's important to recognize that, that Ivory and Mr.
Mackey in particular have been good partners in helping us to— and
working with us to try and solve some of the problems that we've been having.
We We pushed back and forth a little bit, but I, but I want to
recognize that. And I think he just demonstrated it again where he's agreed to build
that Arnot Peak sooner rather than later. I think that's helpful to the city and
not necessarily needful for his project, but it's
certainly helpful to us to accomplish some of the things that we need to do
for our other residents. So I want to express that publicly to you. So thank
you. Thank you, Brock. One, uh, can I just ask a question? This lines up
right on Airport Road, correct? I'm looking at the right place, and I don't know
who to address this question to, but there's a crosswalk to get
across that street. I've come down Airport Road; it's about a 45.
Some people think it's 60. What's that? Fiona.
Fiona. Oh, the road, the cross the cross street on Fiona.
So when you're coming down that 45 miles an hour, you come around the corner,
and then you're right on that crosswalk. And we're just going to
be adding more. cars, traffic in that area. So anything we can do
as a city to make that a safer place,
to bring the speeds down as we approach that, might be something worth considering.
That's going to be something that falls to the city though, Councilmember Huish, not the
developer. So I just— I mean, I think we need to recognize that.
Okay, anything else you want to— it's your time. Anything you want to bring us
up to speed on just for a minute? It's just a discussion
item, so, you know. Nothing really on this one. We're just excited to,
to get it moving and get this park going, and hopefully
we can just keep the momentum going out here for you guys and
for us too. So perfect. Thank you, sir. Yep.
So as far as feedback from council, Mayor, we're good to proceed forward?
I didn't see any concerns. The traffic study, uh, and then if
he'll help us with that road, I think we're ready to move forward on
this one. Okay, thank you. So thank you.
Still, um,
we'll move— I don't see Kyle yet. Is he not here today?
He had to leave for a family emergency. Okay, so— He meant to connect with
you before the meeting. I was— I'll just excuse him. And I forgot because it's
written down lower, but also Councilmember Wood was sick today,
so we'll excuse him and I'll remember to do that later.
Um, so we'll come back to that one another
day. That's what I was waiting, if I was rolling it back in. Um,
we'll go on to 1C. Which was the drive-through locations
and aesthetic requirements for the community development. Mr. Brandon,
is there an applicant here on that one? Was Haskell
or— I invited Bill Gaskell.
Sorry, Gaskell, that's what I meant. Yeah, Bill Gaskell to come
up and just kind of— Okay. Really just wanted to have a really brief
discussion about this. You'll remember back,
I think it was in October, we had,
Council adopted new commercial and
multifamily commercial design standards.
And this is how our screening
requirement reads now for drive-throughs. And so
it makes it so you can't have a drive-through
like on Pony Express or any other— from
a primary street. So that's,
it's an interesting choice of words. Maybe we should have used, anyway,
primary doesn't say collector, arterial,
local, whatever. So as I look at that, that's an
interesting choice. But the, I'm hearing
from not only Mr. Gaskell, but also
there are people who are trying to develop the site across the
street from Walmart, and they're struggling with this as well. When we
proposed this screening
requirement, we were given examples
of people, of cities that are using this screening
for drive-throughs in such a way that they don't— you don't have
them. They're in the back of the restaurant so you don't see them from the
road. But that is really challenging
apparently, and it's challenging for Bill.
He may be explaining this, but I think LOIs
are a big challenge with commercial entities. So just
in short, I just want to know if the council is interested in re-exploring
this requirement because I think it could have potentially a negative
impact on our ability to lure commercial establishments
in the cities that— in the city that use drive-throughs.
So. Mayor. Brandon,
can I ask you, like, what you're asking
us to consider, if I'm thinking about Saratoga where there are
drive-throughs that front primary roads,
Chick-fil-A is a perfect example because it goes around the building almost
the whole way, 3 sides of the building. But it also runs
right along Redwood Road, and then whatever that road
is that you turn off on Redwood Road. And I look at that and I
think, that's not hideous. It's not causing issues.
Right. And part of me feels like sometimes when we
create code, sometimes it takes the application of that code for us to
realize any issues that we might have with it.
Right. Is what we're talking about,
would that allow what's taking place at the Chick-fil-A in Saratoga Springs?
Currently this right here, what we have on the books wouldn't.
What I'm proposing is maybe we just eliminate that requirement.
We didn't have a screening requirement like this prior.
Right. And I think we're okay.
I think one concern we had as
staff was drive-through windows on
the vehicles. funding Pony Express, and at the same time, if it's
gonna hurt business, I guess I'd rather have business than not. But I
just don't think this is something staff's super passionate
about, and I think we're more concerned about commercial development than— I
guess for me, I don't remember the impetus for why someone
was super passionate about it, or multiple people were passionate about it, but I
look at where the drive-throughs are
on some of the primary roads, and I don't see a lot of issues with
it. I could see the business maybe having a complaint of it maybe being
too noisy because of the traffic at some point. Right. But that's also on them
to do the best practices for their business. So yeah, I think that's where I'm
at with this. I think staff was looking at this from,
you know, our— one of the important parts of our job is make
sure the city looks nice. And so we were like, well, can we set it
up so we can still facilitate commercial development while still making our city
look, you know, look attractive. But as we,
we proposed this, we, in application, we're like, no, this,
this is probably going to be more of a hindrance than a, than a help.
So, um, I did invite Bill here.
If— I don't know if you want to hear a, a, his— a comment or
two from him, because he's been struggling and has kind of brought that up to—
brought that to my attention. So I thought it might be helpful to hear something
from So I have a question that
might help clarify some of this, because the code that you're showing just says drive-through,
and the drive alley goes all the way around the building.
Are we talking about the drive-through window? Is that what you just said? Well,
that was part of it. We were just— the idea we
were thinking was like, well, let's put it behind the building.
But I think the biggest thing we were worried about was the drive-through
window. Because the drive alley still circles the
building, right? Still circles the building. And you can set them up so they don't,
but I just don't think staff really cares either
way at this point. We want the city to look nice, but more concerned about
commercial development. Yes. Bill, if you want to address—
Thanks
for having me. My name is Bill Gaskill, for the new members here.
Yeah, I think this code coupled with the requirement
that the building be set up against the property line so
that there's no drive-through, no road between the building and the property
line is problematic.
And really, I guess maybe to give you a couple examples right here,
Chick-fil-A or McDonald's, for example, McDonald's,
delivers their food with a full-size semi-truck, and the
only way they can do that is to drive all the way around the building.
And drive-throughs to go across the street to Chipotle,
Moe Betta's, I forget who's there. If we put
that drive-through lane on the back side of that building, we would have 4 businesses
that customers have to walk across the drive-through lane To
get in the front door, so the code requires the drive-through
to be on the back side of the building or on the side of the
building. The examples were were banks,
which is one business in one building. And the minute
we put four businesses or even two businesses,
you don't have a a you still have another occupant,
and you still have customers that are driving. Across that drive-through
lane, so to go behind the building,
you you can't really go around part of the building and then swing
back out into the parking lot because you're swinging back out into
that main drive aisle right in front of the building. To put
it on the side, you're doing a big loop in
a side parking lot, so you're just creating another field of parking.
and all of those parking stalls in between the drive-through or crossing
the drive-through. So the idea of going, wrapping around
the building is really keeping the drive-through lane
away from your customers, customers' kids.
If, I guess you wouldn't be taking a
grocery cart out, but it's to separate the cars
from the pedestrians. Thank you. I don't think anyone has a problem with
a drive-through window being on the side of the building,
but once you go to the back, you're where the front doors are.
And, you know, drive-throughs are pretty important,
especially most of the drive-through occupants are food users.
And inside of that space, you have a kitchen, and that
kitchen has to be tied to the drive-through window.
And the idea is this flow between
getting your order and getting the food out the door or out the window as
quick as possible. So it's hard to,
if you have customer seating, to rearrange that kitchen and your
customer seating to put your front door and your drive-through
window on the same space. So it's For
for a bank, for a
tire shop, for a loop shop,
it's it's not a problem. But for food and multi-tenant
buildings, it it's a problem.
So we have we would like to be doing
projects right here on this corner. We'd like to be doing things
south of. Holiday Oil. We've,
we've had tenants and we're kind of on
the shelf right now with everything. So is the
ask just for fast food restaurants to move
it to the side versus having it in the back? My— I, I am not
here to give any suggestions because I didn't, I didn't write the code.
If I did give a suggestion, I would say just scrap what you— Altogether?
altogether. Um, because coupled with that, again,
you can't put these buildings right up on the property line,
um, just with the traffic flow.
So I'm not here to give you suggestions. I'm just telling— giving you
some of the issues that we're facing right now with our
tenants. I, I have a question for you, Mr. Gackle. I mean,
and I'm just going to say this, I'm I don't know who's bent
on this being this way. Let me just say it that way. I'm certainly not.
And if we've got this wrong, then let's fix it. Yeah. That's my thought
process. But we need someone like you to help us understand what the problems
are that it's creating. And so my ask would be to have you work with
our planning staff to make a suggestion as to how to correct it so it
functions. From my perspective, the important part of this is the screening
element. I just wanna make sure that those things are screened, even if
there's a drive-through that's adjacent to one of our major roadways, I'd like to make
sure that it's screened with some bushes or a berm or something that just kind
of keeps that separation between the pedestrian traffic that may be walking along
there from that drive-through aisle. So yeah,
we do, we do landscaping, we do berms, small retaining
walls. And I see this as a screening code, frankly.
And so the impact of the drive-through is not something that I've
really been aware of. So it's It's good to hear your input, and my encouragement
would be to get the mayor to let you work with staff and figure
it out. Bring us back something that works. I would agree,
and I think for me the most important thing is what the architectural facade
that faces that main road, that it looks nicer. And,
uh, so I think that combined with, you know, the berming,
the screening, I think that's really for me what it is. I don't really care
where the drive-through is. And if there's a safety issue, I mean, that's something that's
pretty significant. So, okay.
So rather than scrap it, I think the— if I understand
correctly, I want to make sure you understand that we're going to look at,
uh, some berming requirements and, uh,
the facade on the street-facing and
maybe tweak that a little bit. Or some of that's already in our code,
right? And maybe remove the location requirement because I think that that's part
of what's giving you issues, right? I'm glad
to work. Is that agreeable and understood? Yeah,
absolutely. Well, we have a good working relationship with Bill, and we'll definitely
work with him. Because, Bill, we're interested in attracting more business to the city,
not less. And you're the guy that can help us understand how to do that.
And if you're running into these problems, I'm really grateful that you're willing to bring
it forward and let us understand that there's a problem with our code. One of
the things that I
think it would've looked a little more attractive. And that's, so that's what we were,
we just trying to make the city look, you know, make it look nice.
And so I, we'd love to work with
Bill to make it, to make that screening requirement as best
as possible. We thought maybe like some type of awning or some,
something, I don't know, some, I don't know, I mean, just brainstorming. I think
that's what Council Member Whiting is talking about is just, you know, still try to
enhance the front facade even if it has a drive-through on it. Yeah,
yeah. I think some of the code includes that.
Yeah, that's— I think it's in other parts of the code. Yeah,
there's— and there's berming also requirements or screening requirements,
especially against residential, but this will be on a street,
so incorporate that. And I think we'll— You guys iron it out and bring it
back. Yeah, we will. Bill's good to work with. We'll figure
it out. Okay. Okay, thank you. Anything else on that one?
If I can have a little leeway, I wanted to go out of order a
little bit because I wasn't paying attention. But if we can skip to item 13A,
Lead the way. Specifically because I
know I've been up at the state capitol today and I know people are busy
and I wasn't paying attention to who was here. So this
should be quick, but I wanted to jump over. It's a resolution of Eagle Mountain
City. It's on the consent agenda, approving agreement with Hamco Consulting
to provide lobbying services. with Mr. Dan Hammert.
So if you want to come forward, it's really questions
and kind of a meet and greet, if you will, or whatever. Make sure the
mic is turned on. There's a little button. Okay, we're good. Mr.
Dan. Thank you, and happy to wait as long
as it takes. So, um, uh,
yeah, so, so nice to meet y'all. I've met some of you in meetings before,
uh, on other issues, uh, specifically about some,
uh, uranium enrichment stuff, some, uh,
nuclear stuff, and some, uh, Military Installation Development Authority
activity. But regardless, uh, here before you, um,
I'll give you a little bit about my background if that's okay,
and then talk about some of the projects that, uh,
hoping to work on for your city this legislative session.
And then also, you have already a lobbyist, Dave Stewart,
and just thought it might be helpful to talk about how I would work with
So, first of all, about me. I'm relatively new to lobbying. This is my 4th
session, but I'm not new to state government. I served in the state legislature,
in the Senate. I represented Northeast Utah County, where it's
the seat that Brady Brammer is now sitting in. Served there, was the
majority whip in the Senate, and part of the still current
Senate president's leadership team at the time.
When Governor Cox was elected governor, he asked me if I would resign my Senate
seat. I'd just been reelected. I was going to say, and join his cabinet and
run what was then the Governor's Office of Economic Development.
That seemed like an interesting, unique opportunity, so I said
yes to that. I resigned from the Senate and then ran GOED.
I did that for a few years. We changed the name to GOEO, and ironically,
they're changing the name back to GOED this session. I guess
the name didn't stick. Jeff Moss, who didn't
represent this area but was right next to it, is now He was asked
by the governor to resign from the House and head
up that agency, which he's decided to do. So I've had a lot of experience
in state legislature. As a
senator, did quite a bit with transportation, and that's going to be germane to what
I'm hoping to work on with you guys about working with UDOT,
Carlos Braceras and his leadership team specifically. And then
since leaving the legislature, have found there's not a lot of lobbyists that
really specialize in this area. And so given my
relationship with Carlos, I did serve on the cabinet with him and knew him from
before that as a legislator, do have a really good working
relationship with him and his senior staff. And so that's been an area
where I've been hired by a number of groups to help
with funding, transportation-type funding.
Which takes me specifically to what I'm hoping
to work on with you, and I have some notes here I'm gonna refer to,
but mostly it's— Yeah. 'Cause I get nervous and forget
what I'm about to say. But mostly
what I've been asked to work on is the Mid-Valley Highway
specifically. You guys have major transportation issues. There was a—
there was— geez, you know this— going east-west in and out of
this area is a nightmare. I actually— this
is dumb, but I'll still say it— before— or I still own
Red Hanger Cleaners. It's a little dry cleaning company. We actually have a store
in Saratoga Springs. And so I've come
out here. We offer a pickup delivery service, which I've had the fortune or misfortune
of driving those vans around when someone doesn't show up for work.
And I've driven all over this area. And traffic here is not great,
particularly coming out to this area specifically.
Like even today, I came early because I was worried I was going
to be late. And coming off of Redwood,
to turn, to come out into this valley.
I think there was a stackup of cars to turn left there. I think
it was like a quarter of a mile. This was at 3, like 3 PM.
It's crazy. Of course. Yeah. And I know you,
I know I'm preaching to the choir here, but that's the big, I guess
what we're trying to help you with is get more connection access
in and out of this area and specifically the Mid-Valley Highway.
So the big lifts, and I'm actually quite optimistic
already. We've already been working on this. So whether you hire me or not,
it'll probably get done. So I shouldn't have said that. You probably don't need to
hire me. But we've laid a lot of groundwork here.
But what we're trying to do is twofold. One, get the
plans for the Mid-Valley Highway designated as a state road. It's not.
The whole concept's not. So that's number one. And in conjunction of
that, to start UDOT to begin
working on this as a major infrastructure project, because also
it's not. And so what we're working on is an environmental study to get money
set aside for an environmental study to start
moving the project forward. And right
now I'm actually— this is a pretty— how
do I say this in a public meeting? It's like it's hard
to do this. Yeah. And it's hard to get this done in the way we're
doing it. But right now, I'm pretty optimistic. You have an amazing representative
in Stephanie Griecious. She is a bulldog in all the right ways.
And she's great to work with. She's tenacious, and she's
hardworking, and she's been super helpful in this process.
And I think we are gonna be successful this session on
those 2 points. The other areas where I'm working is Cedar Valley Highway. It's another
highway planned, right? Yes. On some specifically, corridor preservation,
and then ideally to get some money to build the first part of the frontage
road on that highway. And that highway's planned, as you may know, 2 frontage roads
with the main highway in the middle. And so start that process.
Some other areas that we have worked
on that have been brought to our attention, Senator Scott Sandel has a bill that
prohibits any sort of incentive and then redistributes any
tax increment coming from data centers. I know that's something
that this community has really focused on as a benefit
to the community. That is a bill that I have engaged in with Senator Sandel.
I think that's going to end up in a fine place. He mostly just put
it out there because he wants to start a discussion, which many
legislators do it this way. His concern is there are going to be some haves
and have-nots relative to some of these larger infrastructure
projects. The haves are going to benefit, and the have-nots are not.
Where he represents a pretty rural area, It's most
of northwest Utah. He's concerned
that his communities, or the communities he represents, are going to be have-nots.
And so he doesn't want to find himself in a
situation where some communities benefit. It's not targeted at Eagle Mountain,
but that is his concern. And I think we'll have a dialogue and a discussion
around that. And then also, I've been
working on a broader UDOT study. that kind of brings
into play all of these connectors that come in and around this valley to
help figure out how to get people in and out of this valley better.
So that is a completely separate kind of process and study that UDOT
is working on or should start working on here in the very near
term. That's— oh, David Stewart. How do I
work with him? I've been brought
on with David on a number of projects. Not that he's deficient. If I was
going to hire a lobbyist, I'd hire David. So, you know, you hired the right
guy. But what I found is different people
just have different relationships and frankly different ideas to
approach situations. And where David and I have worked
together well and we've been hired as a team by a few cities
and even a few counties is different
people have different relationships, but also different people, like I said, have different ideas on
how to approach a project and a process. And specifically to the
Mid-Valley Highway, I happened to be in a meeting,
this was on the other side of the mountains in American Fork, where Senator
Brammer is trying to get some money for a flyover
that comes over the freeway to connect into the FrontRunner station there in American
Fork. And he got talking to me and he
wasn't— he was asking for some advice on how to go about doing it.
And we set up a meeting with UDOT and him and MAG to discuss,
and American Fork, how to move this forward. It was in that meeting where
UDOT asked, they said they would help with it,
but they asked for Senator Brammer to push for some intent language
to get an environmental study started on that project.
It was in that moment and in that meeting where I said, hey, we should
do the same thing for Eagle Mountain City. It's kind of being in the right
place at the right time, but having also different ideas and expertise on how to
approach a problem and get stuff done. And I've,
in the 4 years I've been out of the legislature and on a number of
these projects working with David, I found that we complement each other very well.
And that comes back to, I'm gonna repeat myself
now, but just different relationships and just different ideas
on how to solve a problem. So hopefully that answers your questions. Happy to answer
any questions you may have. Thank you.
Could you just maybe educate us a little bit? How many other
cities are you working with? And I'm more, as I was reading
through this, just thinking about time allocation. You know, there's a specific ask
on a dollar amount, and you don't have to get into like your hourly fee
or anything like that, but I'd be curious just what your bandwidth is and how
much time you feel like you'd be able to allocate to Eagle Mountain.
Because you addressed some really key issues getting in and getting out.
Mid-Valley is So important, we want to get it right and get it prioritized
with the state. It's a great question. On the one
hand, I feel like I always use
this analogy of balls rolling down hills, right? You kick them down the hill and
you watch them roll. We've kicked a lot of those balls down the hill already
and they're rolling quite well. I mean, it still takes some work and effort,
but as far as bandwidth for this session, on the items I discussed, I'm pretty
optimistic on getting those things done this session or significant
progress. Well, the way I described them, actually getting them done. Nothing's done until it's
done, but I'm pretty optimistic. On the other hand, just general bandwidth,
I am busy. And I'll even tell you the other cities I do work
for. So Santaquin, Perry,
Tremonton. So they're kind of far away. And this is where this matters.
I also represent Salt Lake City. This matters because geographically,
UDOT and the state likes to spread the love. Yeah. I know there is a
narrative that for the past few years a lot more transportation money's been going north
than south. I don't know if you've heard that narrative, but it's been out there
for a while. Regardless, and there are some large projects
to the north that are getting funded, but traditionally the state
likes to, again, spread the love or
share dollars based on need and geographically.
And so to that extent, there's not
as much as a conflict with the cities I do represent with this area because
of that desire by UDOT to spread out resources
and not put them all in one place. And so while I
am busy and while I do have other clients, I don't know that they're in
direct conflict. I don't know if that answers your question exactly, but— Yeah,
or more just like out of a 40-hour work week, you know, throughout the year,
or do all— is all the work happening For most
of it, it happens during the session. During the work week? Yeah. So I spend,
I bet it's 16, 17-hour days during the session,
during the work week. On weekends, you're still working. It's not
that much though. I'm gonna guess like last weekend, probably 3 to 4 hours
on Monday and probably 4 to 5 hours on Saturday.
And so the session is definitely the busy time.
For anyone who's a CPA or interacts with CPAs, it's kind of like around April
15th for those folks. That's your busy season.
The rest of the year you are engaged though. I thought
lobbyists only worked during the session.
And what I like to say is either I'm doing it way wrong or I
was wrong because I'm pretty busy year round. So for
example, on your projects, let's say we get them funded.
Those bills are all gonna pass by the end of the first week of
March. Yeah. Right? And they're gonna have effective dates in May. But as soon as
they're done, I know what I'm gonna go do. I'm gonna go start talking
to UDOT about, okay, we got you this
money, how do we get this allocated per the Transportation Commission?
There's other boxes that have to be checked or
hoops that have to be jumped through. And while things do
slow down outside of the session, it's still, I've found at least,
Yeah. 40-hour work weeks and still around
and available. And also what I found is if a
city has issues, I'm absolutely available to go work on them. And particularly
if we're thinking ahead to the next session, that interim period
between the sessions is a very effective time to get ahead on projects
and to get ahead on whether it's funding requests for
transportation or even policy initiatives. I'm making stuff up right now. But let's say
you guys want to modify some stuff you're doing around your energy overlays
or your, you know, your data center stuff you're doing, and you want some state
policy to help support that or modify that.
That interim period is an excellent time, and spending quite a bit of time,
not for you per se, but it can be, but for me, with legislators
getting language drafted ready for the coming session.
So I do think I am around and available
during the session and try to be responsive, but then post-session I'm around and available
to work on issues. And I still go to work post-session
as the follow-up to what happened in the session, but usually the orientation
moves toward the state agencies in the type of projects we're talking about here.
Awesome, thank you. And I noticed in the scope that there would
be a report 2 times a month, which is great. Thank you.
Yeah. Do you do any work to
lobby with UTA? Because we were supposed to get a bus route
and, uh, microtransit, and it kind of fell through.
And we will do whatever it takes to get what our residents need. So I'm
just curious, do you spend any time with that Board of Trustees
or the people that are there? So UTA is getting overhauled this year.
I don't, I don't represent UTA, and, um, my interaction has been
I know our local commissioner pretty well.
That said, the board is getting overhauled again this year,
and my interactions with UTA have both mostly
been affiliated— so I represent Union Pacific Railroad,
and then in interactions between Union Pacific, UTA, and UDOT,
I'm in a lot of meetings with them. So I know a lot of folks
there, but as far as pushing for something like you're describing, I've never engaged on
a project like that, but I think I know the people well enough, the process
well enough, the system, how it works well enough that it could be helpful in
an effort to bring some stuff. I think that's kind of the question, and that's
what I— just to bring the council in on this, is part of
the idea of you being here is for an introduction. The other part is
to give direction on what it is that we want for him to be
working on given that he gets a contract, and I think UTA is one of
those. It's more, I think the question is more of a focus of will you
work with UTA to make sure we get bus routes? Yeah, and Commissioner
Beltran is working on it with Trustee Acerson,
and the idea is Utah County is willing to pitch
in some of the 5th of the 5th to help fund it earlier so
we can get it going. So, and I just feel like they forget that we
account for 1/3 of the growth of the state. So anything
you can do to help rise that to the top, that would be awesome.
For sure. So one other thing that I wanted to bring to— that you
kind of mentioned, but we have funded through 2029 the Eagle
Mountain— well, it's the, um, the freeway to Ranches Parkway.
Yeah, full freeway, and then it ends. And I would say,
I'd hate to throw a number out there, but a good portion, 50% of our
traffic passes that intersection. And it goes to one lane. So we're going to go
from 10 to 1. One of the things that I want to make sure that
we're working on, and I've been working with Carlos a little bit,
is extending at least those frontage roads. You mentioned it,
futurely we want to get those frontage roads at least
past, you know, another mile, if not to Eagle Mountain Boulevard. So that
is, I think, the story that I'm saying that I'm
trying to get you to tell them. Is, uh, we're gonna go from 10 lanes
to 1 each direction, 2 total.
So that's, uh, that's gonna be a huge problem in 2029, and I
wanna make sure that we have a focus on that. Yeah, that's great.
Um, my— when they passed that last year, my suspicion was
that they were gonna go to the next phase, but we wanna make sure.
Yep. Um, were there any other specific bills or anything that we
need? I'll just, I'll just put out some long-range planning kind of some feelers that
we've talked about. I mean, when that freeway comes out and hits Eagle Mountain Boulevard,
turns south, where does it go? And eventually we'd like to see that kind of
connect back up to the Redwood Road area, down into, into the Goshen
area, and return back over to I-15. Yeah. And we want to see some connectivity
out through the Tooele Valley so that we can bypass Salt Lake altogether. If you're
coming in from the west, you can come in on I-80 and
take a belt route that will bring you right through Eagle Mountain. You can avoid
that whole menagerie And I think
I saw the mayor, like you said, up at the Capitol this week, and I
think we talked about that even when we spoke briefly, the connection down from
Tooele. I think that is a natural kind of flow,
right? I just think that, I think long-term we
have to be looking at those things and preserving corridor and starting to figure out
what does it look like 20, 30 years down the road, long after none
of us are here to benefit from it. 'Cause we're gonna have sons
and grandsons and granddaughters and anyway,
that are gonna need to be serviced by those things. Well, and I'll say
something that's unique about your valley is it's developable,
but it's also proximate to the other major urban
centers. So, and you know, I don't wanna say anything too
controversial. Sometimes growth is always controversial. But you're
in a unique and interesting situation where you have land to grow
and with the connectivity, hopefully grow in a way that preserves
quality of life. But where you are and where you're proximate
to those major kind of urban areas, it's a unique situation
that— I mean, Summit County could be this,
but they aren't and won't. But you are in
like a unique geographic— Yeah. area where you could really see some
exciting things from a growth perspective. And sorry if anyone here hates growth, but from
that perspective, you could do some really neat stuff. We,
we did everything backwards. The Field of Dreams movie— if you build it,
they will come. We came, and now we need the building to
happen. So if you can help us get ahead of that curve a couple years,
that would be awesome. Yeah, yeah. The— and
the— and you mentioned SB 231 sandal, right? Uh,
and I'm halfway joking, but if they want us to share, they should share with
us as well, meaning the other cities that already have economic— you know,
it's a— so if we're going to share tax revenue, let's do it
evenly across the board. Yeah, we already do. That's the sales tax. Yeah,
no, we don't. So yeah, obviously we're
a big no on that one. If you can help us on the, uh,
SB 231. I'm sure it's not gonna go as is, and I'm
sure it's not gonna— it's actually, for what it's worth,
it's illegal for him to propose to take local taxes and
redistribute them. We do that, the only place we do that with is school
equalization with the basic levy, but that's a state-imposed tax. It's not
a local tax, and you can't take local,
and he knows this. He and I talked about this, but the effort,
The idea and the effort, his— A for effort. Yeah, yeah,
A for effort on his part. Dan, we appreciate you being here.
Evan, I know that you work within this field. Do you have any other comments?
I know you guys have been talking. And Ben, anything that you need to add,
or are we good? So any questions specific to
today's agenda items so that he can leave? Do we need him to— Need
to go back to the Capitol. Yeah, I knew you had to get back.
That's why I was— I didn't see you at first. I would have come shook
your hand. Um, anyway, I think we're good on that one. So we
appreciate you being here and making the trek out here. You'll see the traffic is
getting worse now. So for sure,
thank you. Thank you all. Appreciate what you do. Thanks for your service.
And I think you serve in the least appreciated
role in government. So thanks for what you do. Thank you.
All right, now we'll get back on track and go to a discussion item 1D,
the community Development Block Grant with affordable housing, and Kiara
has this one from MAG.
And Taylor,
do you need to plug in? I do, and I'm hoping it just is
seamless. But in the meantime, I'm Kiara,
the affordable housing coordinator. I'll let Taylor introduce I'm
Taylor. I work with Mag. Very well.
I am extended, and I knew this would happen, and so now I need to
figure out how to— You'll have to drag it over. Carson's the expert. He'll show
you. Hi. I got you.
We'll just move this over here instead. Other than
I just double skipped. I'll remember this one.
Sweet. Okay,
awesome. Yes, so we are here to discuss the Community Development
Block Grant, also known as CDBG,
um, and that is, um,
the fund we explained in the packet that you guys received for— with our update
and our report. The overall goal here, um, we just want to give you an
update on our previous year Um, for project
year '25, where we are, where we're sitting currently, um, and where
we are hoping to land for our upcoming project year as well.
So we're kind of in the middle of both, um, looking for some direction
and, um, project-specific projects that we'd
like to focus on.
So for the coming year, which starts on July 1st,
but we need to get started planning now, Because our deadline is
mid-May to submit that to HUD.
That's with some comment periods involved. So got
to get started now. Our anticipated allocation is that $239,000
number. That's the one we got this year. Every year it's a little different.
It just depends on the population and
other things that we don't know. The formula isn't public, but it changes a
little bit every year. So we plan it based on the current year.
Uh, between last year and this year, it was like a $4,000 difference, so that's
probably what I would expect again. Um, every year we have a
15% cap on public service, so that'd be about that $36,000
number based on this year. And then every year also fixed administration cost
of $32,000, and that's for us at MAG, but the,
the cap is 20%. So, um, in addition
to that, we have prior year funds of about $7,000.
That's from FY24, so last year. And then from
this year that we're currently in, FY25, we have that $188,000
number that was put toward CAP, uh, the CAP program.
But, um, the city's not wanting to go forward with that,
or that's not, uh, it hasn't
been feasible so far. Um, and then we also have this
FY25 Senior Assistant program that was never carried
out, and that's $3,000. So those last 2 line items are prior
funds that we don't need to plan as urgently as the regular PY26 allocation,
but just to inform you that we need to figure out something to do with
that money. Uh, more urgently is the regular allocation.
The, the regular allocation, which is just that $239,000 number.
Yeah. Um,
yes, so like Taylor mentioned, we have the cap in the Senior Assistance Program.
Um, Right now where we're sitting, the cap— we weren't able—
the goal was to get, um, home-based businesses into a commercial space
and using funds to be able to do so. Um, with the limited commercial space
at the rates that they're at, and, and also we have to focus on folks
in the 80% or less AMI, just the numbers weren't working out and it hasn't
been feasible. Um, so, so far, uh, we haven't
had any businesses make it through the committee, um, to be able to
move forward. So those funds are still available. Um, we do
also have the same situation with our Senior Assistance Program.
Um, that more so just didn't make it through any programming,
so those funds are still available. And before we push those through, we just
wanted to check with you guys to see if there was another allocation for those.
As far as this current year that we're about halfway through goes, the top
portion is all the projects for this year. So, uh,
for the Senior Center addition, we put $17,000 of this
current year and $100,000 of the PY24 funds toward that. And all
of these projects, the work is complete. Um, the top 2, the bus and the
portables, those have already been dispersed. Um, and then in
addition, we've got ADA ramps, which work is complete on that. Um,
utility assistance, which the year has passed for PY24, so work
is complete there. We're also still working on this year's funds, which we're halfway
through that. Okay. And my understanding is that we're— we didn't spend quite
the entire availability for PY24 and
probably won't end up spending the entire amount for this current year as well,
just based on the way it's gone so far. So may
not be as much of a priority in the coming years. And then we did
a one-time back-to-school drive that was back in August.
And then Tabitha's Way was the one organization that the city gave funds to.
outside. Um, and they're also— they've
already spent down all that money in terms of work. We haven't reimbursed them yet.
But yeah, that's the current year. And then this
bottom portion is just kind of a general overview of what is eligible.
So overall, for CDBG, um, the funds
are just meant to benefit low-to-moderate income people. What that looks like
is for every project, at least 51% of people served
must be 80% AMI or under, if that makes
sense. So 2 percentages there, but basically at least
51% of people served for each project have to be low to moderate income.
And you can keep track of that in various ways.
We get into it more in the packet, but like for public service, we have
to check income for every single person that benefits from the service.
And then for things like the ADA ramps, you know, we'd have
to make sure that we're doing it in a census tract that is LMI or
at least 51% LMI. Okay. Or in the case of the ADA ramps, it serves
disabled people, which is that bottom line, presumed eligible groups.
We don't have to track income. So always easier to do a project
that is for a presumed eligible group.
Okay. And so our ideal submission deadline date
would be at the end of this month. So we are hoping to be able
to get a project list confirmed and finalized over to
HUD, and any changes that may come as well.
And so just to reiterate and kind of re-explain,
the unused funds from project year '25,
those are more flexible. That's kind of our past date funds that
just need to be reallocated. The less flexible deadline is the
upcoming project year and the new funds that are coming in and what we want
Um, so in the past, like, I— from that overview of this
year, you've only given a couple thousand dollars to the outside organization
Tabitha's Way. We do have an application process,
so these are the outside organizations that have applied for this coming year.
Um, we also have their full applications for you to review, but this is kind
of just like an overview. All of these are public service,
so these would all be subject to the cap. They're all aware that there's not
very much available. So, you know,
probably only one of these would even be able to get funded.
But these are all of the applicants, and we have
more full comments based on my pre-application meetings with them in your packet.
But yeah. Thank you.
Okay, and that is all we have.
Um, Council, one of the things that we've heard, and this kind of came up
a little bit on our retreat, is that people often say, well, there's nothing
for the teens to do, and there's lacking in
things. And yet our library does a ton of programming,
and we also have a teen center here in Eagle Mountain that
is housed at the Rockwell High School And they also have a
very robust food pantry there. And if
we're coming up short with ideas of where we should be spending
this money, I wholeheartedly think we should be looking at putting some
of it toward the teen center and boosting that up and
really just kind of owning it as a community until we can get another
one built that's within the programming of the school. Thank you. The city,
so that's one thing. The other thing that I think that we need to be
looking at, especially for lower-income families that are struggling,
is some sort of utility help. And I know that we have some
programs, but there's also issues where they get behind
and different things like that, and they would qualify. And I think it's important
to keep the taxpayers squared away so that they're
not just giving up money. So if there's a program that we could create and
a way to shore up different
households that are really struggling and make sure they have the utilities that they need,
those are the 2 areas that I see that we can make a really big
difference with the amount of money that we have remaining for this year.
Can those funds be administered by the city? Like if we had a discretionary utility
fund and a process to screen those
applicants I'm not sure.
Kimberly's giving us a look, so I would just ask the mayor to invite
her up. Yeah, that's fine. We'll let finance
speak to that. Yeah, definitely. Okay, Kimberly, if you want to— Yes and
no. I mean, I love that idea. I really do.
I couldn't tell you why she's coming up, but in January there were people that
still hadn't paid their utilities from, I think, September, October. And it was a madhouse
in here, right? Correct. So any funds that we
receive through the CDBG program will still retain those particular restrictions.
But yes, we have everything in place to be able to administer that.
Originally with the funds we received, we were looking at a bridge that would help
with the peak water usage. So similar to the heat program
that MAG administers, if you're familiar with that, in the wintertime it helps pay
utility bills for electric and natural gas services,
then we were looking at utilizing this to help kind of create that bridge during
those peak seasons. However, it's not restricted for only water usage.
We can use it to provide utility assistance for the
entire utility bill at— as long as they're
meeting the income qualifications and the age qualifications if it's a senior-related
type situation. So we
typically do require some portion of
a commitment. So again, we'd be looking— in general, when you do these
programs, you want the dollars to be able to switch, to stretch,
and you want to be able to help as many people as possible.
We would need to look at our current policy that's
adopted, and we would have to make some modifications for this, but it is something
internally we've talked about and 100% support
and feel like there is a need, and we'd look for opportunities that we can
provide additional assistance. Thank you.
Awesome. The other thing that I'm curious about, and I don't know if it's something
that we could use the money for, but it feels like we have this
smattering of resources that are available within our community.
We see the nonprofit applications that come in and the desire
that they have to help, but there's not really any one-stop shopping for
people who are in need in this community. Typically, you don't make hiring
choices based off of money that you're not sure how much it's going to be
from year to year. But part of me feels like we could even have a
part-time person in our city that could help when people
come with resources and help get that information out
to the people in need. But also, when people have needs and they come in,
and maybe they're referred through the utility program. program,
and/or the community outreach people at the
high school, that we have someone that's kind of
a point person. I don't want to use the word caseworker because there's a different
connotation, but really it's someone who understands the social services
that are out there, and we use these funds to
hire even a part-time person to stretch the funds so
that people have an easier time accessing them. and are aware of them.
And I'm just wondering, is that something we can use the Community Development
Block Grant funds for? Yeah, I mean,
I think— correct me if I'm wrong,
but, um,
all the backups. This one
is a little complicated, so thank you for letting me jump in. Um, you could
use the funds to do that. for a part-time
position, it would fall under the public service cap, so that smaller
15%, and you could only do it to create a
new position, so one time, or to expand
a position, and so it wouldn't be ongoing funding that you could use that
for. Yeah. Thank you. Can I ask
one more question? I live in Sage Valley, and for many, many years we
had this little pavilion. It was kind of out in an island of grass.
There was no connecting path from the sidewalk to the pavilion,
and we had a neighbor that was in a wheelchair, and we'd carry her to
the pavilion and then carry her back. Otherwise, she's kind of rolling uphill
on grass. It was kind of difficult. Can these funds be used for things within
the city to make them ADA accessible? And have we done any kind of assessment
throughout our parks to make sure that everything is connected? They can
absolutely be used for Yeah, we would just need to make sure it was in
an LMI census tract or that you did a cert— like a survey to see
if the service area is at least 51% LMI. But if it's for disabled individuals
particularly, yeah.
Okay, sure. Okay,
do we, do we have any LMI areas in Eagle Mountain? Do you know?
We do, yeah. We have maybe 4 pockets.
Yeah, 5 census tracts. So in those areas we could see if
improvements can be made. It seems to me that we should evaluate those areas to
see how the parks, if there are dilapidation within the parks and put money toward
that. Would that come out of the 15% cap or is that— That's separate.
So the cap program that didn't work, we could put it towards these
parks and rec in the LMI areas, which I think is a great idea.
Yeah. I guess another quick question. So dumpster
programs. Can that— does that fall under this as well? Or is it only
dumpsters for LMI areas? Like a cleanup dumpster?
Yes, as long as it's like a one-time kind of cleanup effort.
Anywhere in the city? It's coming from the 15% cap though. Oh, it is coming
from that, which is— which that's the part that's limited. And I don't think we
want to hire staffing to take up that 15%. I think we want that
15% to get— yeah.
I mean, some of the things I've been thinking about— I met with the school
district and kind of their staff members who— one
of the issues that we really have at this, at the high school, is transportation
issues for, for people who are in the LMI. Just getting to school,
getting back and forth to school, getting to work, getting to doctor's appointments,
and those types of things. I'm not sure how to solve that problem, but I'd
love to see us put some resourcing towards that, especially where we're so
far from some of those services at the the county. Mhm. Um, I don't know
how we coordinate that or how we do it. And then I'm thinking about homeless
and homeless— homeless center. Just, we have a higher homeless population
in Eagle Mountain than I think most of us realize, and we have students that
are homeless who are coming to school every day and trying to make, make it
work. And I, and I like your idea, Council Member Clark, about having some,
some resource center where those who really do find themselves in that
LMI category and, and with those needs can come and access those
things, whether it's transportation, food, clothing,
just the basic human element that needs to help meet
their basic human needs and to help get them back on their feet
and headed in a direction that will help them become better educated,
perhaps enter the job— into the job
market because they now have access to some sort of
transportation system. I could see Councilmember Clark with her little hat and her minivan,
and she can just go pick them up all day and kind of drive around
the city. In a high-vis vest. But I just think that there are
some of those things that we need to be thinking about. How can we in
Eagle Mountain start to organize and
have those resources available to our people who are really in those circumstances?
And there are more of them than we realize.
So we had this discussion. What happens next? How do we get
from this conversation to get some of the
funds where they need to go? We just, I mean, these are
all very great ideas. So we can either come to you guys with project suggestions
on what you've mentioned that would fit kind of these different areas and
make them feasible, or vice versa. You guys send us any other specifics and
we can Work it that way, but— One
last thing that I thought of, sorry. I'm thinking about workforce development and
people who may be returning to the workforce or underskilled.
We're so far away from a Department of Workforce Services. We have
someone from DWS that comes out to Eagle Mountain 1 to
2 times a month and meets with employers to help them
know what to do, but part of me wonders if We could use some of
these funds to help with maybe a job interview
workshop and resumes and even clothing
to help them get on their feet so they can look decent for a job
interview. And I just don't know what that program looks like, but that feels
like an area that we probably need to address as well.
Yeah, that's actually a great area for CDBG specifically because it,
it sounds like it might be a public service, but it would count as economic
development. something like that. I kind of detailed it in your report
that you received, but yeah, like funding some kind of job
training program, that would be economic development, so it wouldn't be subject to
the cap. Yeah. So I think the best thing is,
are your emails in the presentation at all,
or— No, but I can get those over to
you guys. If you don't mind, because I think we can take the discussion today
And, uh, and then if there are any other ideas of, hey, what about this
area, if you'd share with us the 5 areas so that we can get a
look, and then let's send it back to them, have them bring us back the,
the some project ideas. I think that's how we kind of did it last year.
Um, we had a few that took up a lot of the budget, but if
they can come back with some project ideas— but I want everybody to be able
to send the input. Yeah, that'd be awesome. So if,
if we get your emails and you would Do you want us to go through
you or both, I guess? I'll include Taylor. OK, Taylor, make sure we
get your email. Sounds good. So any other comments or questions?
Perfect. Awesome, thank you guys. Thank you.
All right, that's the last of our discussion items, so we'll go ahead and review
the consent agenda.
Let's go to item 11.
So we're going to start off with item 11A, Harmony Phase A and
the warranty. And I'm just going to read these if you have any questions.
Ranches Crossing, Plat A and the warranty.
Okay, item 12 is the minutes from City Council
from July 1st and then January 29th. All right.
What did I say? I read ahead. July 1st, January 29th,
uh, January 30th, and February 3rd.
All right, the resolution we talked about,
13A, there's no need to revisit that.
13B, um, a resolution of Eagle Mountain,
Utah, authorizing extended hours for construction operation for
the 4 million gallon Scarlet Ridge water tank. I have a question about
that, Mayor. Is that just for those, um, overnight pours and then it goes
away? Yes. And I think— did you want to— okay,
that's correct. So this first pour is going to be in the next 2 or
3 weeks. That's for the floor slab. They're going to start around 1:00 AM,
finish around 8:00. They're going to have 2 pumps there.
Um, should be done, should be about 500 yards roughly.
And then the next 5 to 6 months, they'll do The roof slab.
The wall slabs they can do during the day. They may start kind of early,
like 6, 7, but they can do those during the day. Perfect.
That's, that's all I want to know. Is it, is it just— yeah, and Melissa's
up here saying 6, 7, 6, 7. She heard you. My teenagers make
me do it. She's whispering in my ear.
But that, that makes— I mean, that, that makes sense. I just wanted to know
if it was limited to just those times when they're going to pour. So it'll
be Correct. When they're doing a continuous board. Yes.
Good. Any other questions on that one, 13B?
All right, that's all of our consent agenda,
but since we have a little bit more time,
I'm debating going to the end of the agenda to Kimberly's item,
but I think we'll get to it anyway, so be ready.
First item on our agenda is 14A, discussion of
the 5th Amendment to— and this is just a discussion item, so I want to
know, uh, if we do that now, we won't have to do it later.
Is everybody here, Marcus, that needs to be here for that one?
Um, I don't think so. Well, I think that the applicants kind of want
to be here when we discuss it, but— That's why I was— So I think—
I don't know who's all here. Oh, okay. Oh, yep. Sorry,
I didn't see you. Yeah, so I think we can discuss it
if they're here. And because it's a discussion item with no action, but it was
noticed that for the 7 o'clock meeting, do we need it?
Well, we put agenda review on the work session,
so we can review the agenda and talk about it now. And if there's additional
discussion to be had in the 7 o'clock hour, we can do that
as well. Okay, I do wanna get to that one.
Right now so that we can get it out of the way.
So— Mayor, I think it would
be good for the public to be able to hear and be a part of
that discussion if people come at 7. Are you opposed to just letting it
stay in the 7 o'clock timeframe?
Not particularly. It is after public comment, so— All
right. Either way, I just, I don't want to shortchange it because it is such
a big deal. Is there anything we should talk
about now then, and I'm just— I'm to get any of it out of the
way, or you want to hold on the whole thing? I am
assuming that we're going to get a presentation like Planning Commission got,
and I feel like that was useful to the people
who were there to know what's going on. We had some residents that came to
Planning Commission last week with very specific questions about the project,
so I anticipate some Okay,
I'm fine holding that one off. You guys are sticking around, so let's
wait on that one. Sorry. Great, it's gonna be a good discussion.
So the next one, 15A, resolution of
public hearing, the second amendment to the
budget. I'm gonna come
back to that one because I wanna get to the other budget one first,
I think, if that's okay. So we'll
skip down to 16A, resolution of Eagle Mountain City authorizing the issuance and sale of
the bond. Is that Ben?
Yes, Kimberly and I can answer questions now, but Laura Lewis
is not gonna be here until 7:30. Sorry,
hold on. She's not feeling well, so she's gonna be joining us virtually.
Okay. Is there anything, questions now on that one?
And are you good for this one, or?
This one I have to recuse from any discussion or voting. Okay. On the
bond. That's what I was asking. So we're aware that that will happen.
And I think we may have answered this, but let me clarify. So there is
a call on, like, when interest rates drop,
the city would have an opportunity to refinance those, call those back and get
lower rates. Yeah, I think this is one where we'll want to have Laura
answering those questions as the financial professional. Well, and I think that's
also a question once they issue the bond. This is just the resolution so
we can get the bond. So it's— that wouldn't be in this discussion, I don't
think anyway, right? We can ask Laura. I've got
a comment about some of the— so the way that the language was
written, the mayor and the city manager would have
power to pull a trigger. Given that it is such a high dollar
volume, I think it's safer to still have City Council be
involved with that. It's just that it's a, it's a big amount.
Is that because we might have to go meet with the bond
counsel, or? Yeah, again, I think this would be a good discussion
to have with Laura because she can walk us through the entire process and all
that type of thing. Just making sure. There are timelines involved. I don't know that
it's a A grave concern or anything like that. And of course, we want the
council to be comfortable and the community to be comfortable at every step of the
way. But she could definitely walk us through every step of that process.
Okay, so I'm going to hold off on that one.
We're going to talk about that later. So 17A
is an ordinance of Eagle Mountain City amending the Municipal Code 1519 and
adopting the wildlife urban interface. They called this the WUI map.
So is there any questions or concerns?
Or Brandon, there you are. Okay.
Does anybody have anything right now? Is there a presentation or anything on this?
Yeah, I think we'll just wait. I— it's unless you have any specific questions
to get through. Okay. Um, and then 18A, the ordinance
of Eagle Mountain City refilling act, chapter 2.3. The Parks and Recreation
Advisory Board, 2.4, the Recreational Sports Board,
2.55, Cemetery Board, and Chapter 2.6, Military Veterans
Board, 2.7, Economic Development Board, and an acting Chapter
2.80 Eagle Mountain Municipal Code to establish
Community Services Board that will encompass
those other boards and including with the RAP tax. So in
your packet was items there. Natalie has this item.
Um, and a presentation, some red lines.
All right, good afternoon, Mayor and Council.
Um, yeah, I'm, I'm really just here— I don't have
a presentation, but I'd like to address any questions, comments, or concerns
you have about the code. Um, I did keep it pretty general,
um, and left in there the ability for the board
to be able to make their own, like, bylaws and kind of run things
themselves, of course with the council's approval on those
things. So I did keep it pretty boilerplate to allow that flexibility
in there, but I can tighten up anything you'd like as well.
Just one quick question I had. I saw that
it requires the board to give an annual report to the city council.
Is there— what's the thinking behind annual?
Does it need to be more than annual? I mean, I'm just— that was one
question I had. If that— is that sufficient? Oh,
sorry. I actually think that we should have it be
at minimum twice a year, ideally more like once a quarter because
they're taking on all of the duties of the rest of
those boards. And I think especially at the beginning, we're going to want more contact.
I know that we have 2 council members assigned as liaisons, but I
also think it's useful to get the feedback from the body
as a body. So. Yeah, I was— I, I would agree.
I think this is great what you put together here. I would just say maybe
a little bit more frequent, quarterly, especially with this being tied to the the
RAP tax funds, we'll probably want to get some idea generation
going sooner than later.
This will also have, I think, 2 staff members,
Steve and— I can't remember the other—
Brad, maybe? I think I would be the main staff member, and then
we would invite, you know, Brad. It depends
on the topics for that evening, that agenda.
We'd invite Parks and Rec, or Parks, we'd invite Recreation,
we'd invite Dawn for events, and anyone
else that makes sense based on the topic. Finn maybe for cemetery.
It just depends. Yeah.
It's somewhat related. I know that we're going to be able to start collecting
these in April. It's going to take a while for it to accrue,
but part of me is wondering Would the 250/30
celebration and different things that we're talking about with the budget tonight
be eligible for WRAP tax funds? Is that something
we could even use those funds for?
Because it's cultural heritage,
those things. So long as it's recreation, arts, or parks
as a nexus, you certainly can use those, those funds. funds will
really— Those
funds will, you know, you just need to make the tie back that it's going
to be of benefit to the residents. So if, let's say, you're doing a dedication
of a new venue or something of that nature and you're having
it as a 30-year, you know,
related event, you know, as long as you have a nexus
and a tie, to Recreation, Arts, and Parks,
you should be okay. But the, the big thing is that the
money will start to be collected by the actual businesses in
April, and those businesses that turn it in will turn it
in either on a monthly or quarterly basis when they file taxes. So the money
will actually really start coming in,
um, in, in July timeframe. So it's half a year,
and just kind of meant to set expectations to,
you know, that FCOM income thing.
Yeah, so in Section 280020,
Board Members and Terms of Office, the 3rd paragraph down,
it says all members shall serve terms unless they voluntarily resign
or are removed in accordance with EMMC 2.30.100,
but we're actually removing that from the code. So I don't think that should be
in there. I think we're going to want to remove that because we're talking about
repealing that section of code. So if it references that,
it will reference a code that's been repealed. Um,
that is my mistake. I apologize. I meant to reference a
different part of code. And maybe I'm wrong, Natalie,
but that's how I read that. Yeah, no, that's what, what's there, and that's what
we're doing. Um, I did mean to reference— sorry, I'm just pulling it up here.
If it just referenced the, the, the, the, the number,
it's 280.100 removal.
I mean, then, then, then it's headed in the right direction. Yeah, that's what I
meant to do. Or like, I think we have another section of
code about how we appoint and remove, and so I
would reference that. It's like 2.27.
I'm glad you caught that. That was just— I just mistyped that.
But yeah, I will fix that before I just wondered— Policy session.
And then let's see, administrative control.
I'm just
curious about Section C or number C in 280060,
Powers and Duties. It talks about administrative control reserved.
It says, except as set forth in this article or by resolution, all other administrative
control with respect to the various committee service departments
departments is reserved to the mayor and city council or designee. And I'm curious,
if it's reserved to the mayor and the city council,
who's going to assign the designee? Is the mayor going to do that? Is the
city council? To me, I think there's just some— there's— we need to clean that
up and just decide who's going to pick a designee.
And I'm not uncomfortable with anyone in that sentence
doing it. I'm not uncomfortable with the mayor doing that or the city council So
it doesn't matter to me. I just feel like we need to clean that up
a little bit. This was pulled from like an example from other
cities. And if I'm understanding, I don't know,
I can be corrected here, but the idea was that to make
clear that the city still does like retain
all decision-making power, that this board doesn't then control
those departments, but rather works with the departments.
Well, I can reword that so the designee's less vague.
We could put staff or whatever
you want. I think it's fine that it says mayor and city council,
but I think we should be clear about who's going to make that, because if
a designee is assigned, who's going to do it? Okay, yeah, I'll clear that up.
That's really the question is if a designee is chosen, then who's going to do
that? So the city that this came from has,
I'm familiar with that city. Oh, I think I know
which one it is. Which binder do you have? Where it has mayor-designee
or mayor-council-designee. What that city does is the
mayor then issues a delegation of authority letter at the beginning of their term
that basically says anywhere it says designee within that code or within
the employee policy and procedures manual, there is literally
a table that mayor says, I'm designating this to this and whatnot.
And then the power could be retracted to them if they want to issue
a new letter or further distributed out. In this particular case, the community service
director— community services director, which we don't currently have one, but it's
a dual title with Steve, would be the designee in that city.
I don't take any issue however you want to organize it. I just want to
make sure it's clear. No, that's a, that's a great question. I'll clear that up.
'Cause that's a little, for me at least, that's a little confusing. And then
I wanted to look at this one and see what my wife wrote
on this. Oh, go ahead. Just to be clear,
when I see administrative control, that is not regarding
to the funds themselves that will be generated. This is
more just the, can you maybe clarify that?
Sure, so the council establishes the budget and basically takes
the recommendations coming from the Community Services Board,
and they then execute that as a budget. The administrative act is
then to execute that budget or implement those projects, and that's
usually done through their city staff under the direction of the mayor, which in fact
would be the Community Services Director. Thank you. Yep,
which really means from Ben, only because
he delegates to me and I delegate out. And I think that's
what it was, so you're good.
Okay, no other questions? I think we're— All right. We'll look
forward to that discussion. All right. Thank you.
The next one, I was gonna see where we— Can I ask one question on
that? So I've heard there was annual, there was semiannual, and then I
heard quarterly. We just wanna make sure that if she's— Natalie's rewriting it,
How often do you want them to report back?
How often have you seen it function, Ben? You have the most experience with this.
I mean, how often?
Typically you have them recommending to
you what they think should be spent. You approve it and
whatnot. Then they come back and report on how it's going, and then they
come back every 6 months going through that. There's nothing to
say that you can't invite them to come back more often. It's just this is
the minimum standard. I think semi is good.
Okay. I think that it's
important when we do use this that there's 2 times that they're coming to talk
about the administration of the grants and 2 times where they come and we give
them responsibilities that we want them to work on, because there are things
within the arts, within recreation and parks, and I
don't want it to be a 2-meeting-a-year responsibility.
There's a lot that we need them to do, and we're dissolving
a lot of boards to create this one. So I just want to make sure
that, yes, maybe the code says semiannual, but we're
putting these people to work and we're bringing them in frequently so we can get
that accomplished. And maybe it can say semi— at least semiannually,
or, or, uh,
additional meetings may be held if necessary. Something like that, just so that,
so that it's clear that, that more may be required.
Okay, this, uh, I held off
on this one to see if we had time for the other discussion, but we're
just going to go back to 15A, the resolution of Eagle Mountain City approving the
Second Amendment annual budget. So Kimberly,
would you give us some information on this one?
And then I think we'll hold off as planned for the other budget
discussion.
Mayor, do you want me to walk through the PowerPoint
in the session here, or just go over questions and things you have in the
work session and then and do the PowerPoint
during the policy session for citizens. Tell me what you
need. I think just the discussion, we can save the PowerPoint. I mean, I think
the staff's pretty familiar, right? Or sorry, staff, the council. Or do you want to
see the presentation now? I think it's better
to save the PowerPoint for when the public's going to be here because they can
really benefit from it. So just to repeat. That's what I was
thinking. So then as far as questions and stuff that we know now,
that we can address.
Go ahead. I have one question, Kimberly. There's a budget amendment that has
to do with the Pony Express repairs by Silver Lake. Are we paying the full
cost? Are we contributing a portion of that? How is that being— So right
now, the request for that is the full cost
of what it was for us. So we funded it originally just out of the
operating maintenance budget for streets. And so retracting
it, if we don't refund it, it will reduce the amount of overlays and maintenance
that we can do on the road system for this year. And when the project
was initially coming, we just weren't aware how extensive or what the repairs might look
like with that. So the goal with this is that the money is being
added back in from restricted funds we already
have on hand that are utilized for the streets repairs and maintenance or
infrastructure and can only be used for the street's
purposes. So this money being added in allows us to continue
with what we had originally planned. Since this was an unplanned maintenance item,
it'll let us do those additional maintenance needs during the summertime
as well. Thank you. I do believe that there has been some conversations
regarding whether there'll be a contribution from
the, from the other community, but I'm not aware of where that sits
right now. Yes, so we are actively working on putting a claim in with
our insurance company and working with our neighboring city, Saratoga Springs.
Thank you. That's really, that's really what I was looking for, is that clarification.
So thank you.
One question I had is, and I'm trying to find it in the documents,
like sideways on my thing, so I'm trying to find it looking this way,
but I got to flip, I've got to flip it around, but It
seems like there was, I think, a traffic study for Golden
Eagle and Silver Lake Parkway, and,
and I'm questioning, is that something we, we should be spending our money on?
Do we want those connections in place? Because I've heard from some people in
that area of great concerns with the elementary schools that are right there.
And yeah. I would say that's exactly why
we want to spend the money on it, because that is the impetus for maybe
a pedestrian tunnel or changing a light so
that it's a better intersection for safety. Absolutely. Or, you know, any of those things.
And this is just arming us with data so that we can make
good decisions about those areas. They have been areas
of concern that residents have brought to us. And I think that's why we as
a council said, and this was last year, just to give more context for you,
we said, as long as we're doing these traffic studies and we're doing our transportation
master plan, Can we please look at these specific areas
that we receive a lot of emails and questions about? So I
hope that helps clear it up. Okay, yeah, that sounds good. I, I did— I
think it's something we need to be open to considering not connecting. I think,
I think we need to look at all the possibilities here and,
and do, I think, what's safest for the residents,
especially. I mean, I went down there, um, at this location
and watched kids running across the street At
places they shouldn't be running across the street. And I've driven,
you know, when I've driven and shown homes in Silver Lake when school's
getting out, it's mayhem going down those roads.
And if these suddenly connect into a high school, they're all— instead
of channeling, you know, traffic down our bigger corridors,
we're starting to channel them through neighborhoods. It's going to be problematic.
Agreed. And I live near one of the schools in question off
of Golden Eagle, Brookhaven. That's our neighborhood elementary school, so I'm very
aware of the little kids and big kids, frankly, that cross there.
I think this will help us make our best decisions about what
we connect and what we don't.
It'll also— it also— I mean, just to speak to that, if you'll
allow me, Council Member Whiting, it also will help us understand the
impact of making some of those connections, the expense
of the additional infrastructure that's going to be required if we
do or if we don't make those connections. Because if that connection is
made, it may precipitate us needing to put some signals into some residential
neighborhoods, traffic signals. They don't
give those away anymore. They never did, but they're getting more and more expensive.
So I think that's part of the reason why we want to look at what
the data so that we can make a good informed decision about
how to move forward there.
Any other questions on the budget amendment as presented?
Nothing? Seeing nothing. Okay.
Thank you. That's most of what
I think we can get through. We do have a closed session item since we
have time. Uh, I'm open to doing that now.
None of us have the agenda. Wait, do you have one?
Oh, you do? Do you wanna— Craig's got it.
I've got it here, Craig, if you want me to— Go ahead. Okay.
Mayor, I move that the City Council adjourn into a closed session for the purpose
of discussion of pending or reasonably imminent litigation
the character, professional competence, or physical or mental health of an individual;
the purchase, lease, sale, or exchange of real property; a
proposed development agreement, project proposal, or financing proposal
related to the development of land owned by the state or a political
subdivision; and/or the deployment of security personnel,
devices, or systems pursuant to Section 52-4-205
Subsection 1 of the Utah Code Annotated.
Second. All right, we have a motion by Councilmember Clark and a second by
Councilmember Whiting, and we'll start the vote with Councilmember Clark. Yes. Councilmember Wright.
Yes. Councilmember Whiting. Yes. Councilmember Hughes. Yes.
Okay, we'll adjourn to closed session.
All right, everybody, welcome. As is our tradition, we're going to start
with the opening prayer, and our assistant manager Steve Mumford
is going to offer that.
Heavenly Father, we're thankful for this evening. We can gather together
and discuss the needs of the city, and I ask you to please
bless everyone who's here to be able to
have their voice heard and participate. And please bless the
mayor and city council with wisdom and
to be able to make good decisions for our residents and businesses.
I say to please bless those that are traveling and our families
at home as well with safety and health. And please bless,
uh, first responders and, and our military.
They will receive thy blessing
of protection and, and, uh,
peace as well. And, and I say this
in the name of Jesus Christ, amen. Amen. All right,
thank you. We'll officially call this meeting to order. It's the February 17th
City Council meeting, and the time is 7:09.
Um, at this time, we want to excuse Councilmember Wood,
who has been ill, and wish
him well to get better. And, uh,
With that, we'll start with the Pledge of Allegiance, and our officers from UFA
will help lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance. If you'll all rise.
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States
of America and to the Republic for which it stands,
one nation under God, indivisible,
with Okay,
thank you. Um, we're going
to start. Are there any information items, Ben? Did you have any for today?
Do we— Yes, we do have a neighborhood
meeting set up with our council on February 19th, Thursday.
Out in Parkway Fields, is that correct? Correct. And from
6 to 8 PM? Yes. And so we invite the public out to that as
well. Okay, any others that we know of,
Lacey or anything? Nothing? Okay,
thank you very much. We have some recognitions,
and I think we're gonna start with Chief Eric.
Knutson is going to introduce— I— oh,
there you are. I was like, where'd he go? He was— we
have a, a replacement for one of our long-lost friends.
Mayor, Council, Mr. Reeves, um, a few weeks ago we said goodbye
to Lieutenant BJ Echols. What I failed to do is mention
who the new lieutenant was, so my apologies. I'd like to introduce,
uh, him to you and the staff and the public is, uh, this is
Lieutenant Jeff Robinson. And, uh, Jeff's been with the Sheriff's Office
24— 3. 3 years. Started out in the jail for
a few years. Um, after that he went to patrol, and he's done everything
from K-9, uh, sergeant to Internal
Affairs to detectives for many years. He worked for me when we
were in the Detective, uh, Bureau for quite a bit. We handled several pretty good
cases together. I've known Jeff for a long time. He did spend a few years,
a couple of years out here in Eagle Mountain years ago as a deputy.
Absolutely loved it. Had a good time out here. And I'd
like to welcome him out here. He's a great guy. I think he's a good
fit with our team that's out here now with the deputies. He knows a lot
of them. His last assignment was Internal Affairs.
So we're no longer as scared of him as we used to be. And so
But he's got a wealth of knowledge, and he's done the background on probably the
last 20 or 30 deputies we have hired. Maybe if that's on the road,
not in the jail, more there. But anyways,
Lieutenant Jeff Robinson. I don't know if you have any questions of him or anything.
You're okay. Thank you. Yeah, thanks. We've already had the privilege
of being in some meetings, and don't tell BJ this, but he's way better.
Well, no, I'm going to tell him.
Uh, thanks. Welcome, Jeff. Um, all right,
and we have a couple more introductions with that. We love
our first responders, our relationships with both the sheriffs and UFA. So,
Ambra, I feel like I spent the whole day with you today.
We started at 7:00, 7:30 this morning, right?
Yeah, unfortunately for you. Yeah, you guys will come up.
Uh, so, Mayor, Council, appreciate the opportunity.
Uh, this was a request at, at kind of the request of
council a couple months ago. I mean, as normal, Eric is the
first responder. We were second responders. But being requested by
council after he started introducing all his deputies, the request
was to kind of get names to faces and see who is
here serving the community. One of our other crews just
was clearing a gas call. They may show up. And then we had I
think we have a motor vehicle accident that our other crew is on right now.
So this is the crew out of Station 253, Mid-Valley, the new
station that opened up last year.
So Captain Wayman moved into that position when
that station opened up, and so I will turn it over to Captain Wayman.
Captain Wayman has been around for a long time, coming up 20 years,
and it's been a huge part. He's a huge part of the Honor Guard
and does a lot for us in that regard. And so anytime we have
any funerals or parades or anything like that, he pretty much spearheads
and wrangles everybody and kind of herds cats to
make that all happen. So I'll turn it over to Captain Wayman to introduce his
crew, and if you have questions, let us know. Thank you,
appreciate the opportunity. And for the cops, I just want to make it clear
that You know, everybody knows there's one thing that's common
between cops and firefighters. They both wanted to be firefighters.
So— But I'm very happy to be able to introduce my crew.
This is Travis Clappy. He's actually a resident of
Eagle Mountain for over 12 years now.
He's an engineer, been 22 years on the department.
This is Ashley Files. She's a paramedic on the
truck today. She just got how
many Stork Awards? 2. It's a Stork Award for delivering babies.
She's very good at it. She's good at catching babies.
And then firefighter Christian Faber is her partner
on the truck today. We have 2 other members that are on the call,
so our ambulance is the first-out ambulance in this in the city, and they're,
they're out with the other station on a traffic accident right now. So appreciate
the opportunity to let us introduce them and see their face.
Thanks, guys. I appreciate you helping us with the honor guard and flag ceremony.
Thank you. Can we, can we give the firefighters and our,
and our deputies just a round of applause? Absolutely.
One of the— I wanted to point out one of the advantages. This is something
that I've been dealing with a ton the first couple of months at the meetings,
is whether or not we have 4-handed crews or 3-handed crews and the budget
for that. And of course, we have 4-handed crews here. That's why
you see 4 on the truck, and it is essential. I think we— Foster and
I talked this morning about the difference, and we really appreciate the support
from UFA, but then the crews as well. So thanks for coming, guys, and thanks
for all that you do in our city keeping us safe.
All right, moving right along. Time has been set
aside for public comment.
We— I know I want to start with this
little, uh, saying, uh, uh, what I read every time.
Sorry. As a reminder, public comment is an opportunity for
community members to address the City Council, and each speaker is allowed up to 3
minutes. If you wish to speak during the public comment or
public hearing portion— if you wish to speak during the public
comment of the public hearings portion, please complete the comment form located in
the back of the room and return it to the city recorder, Lacey,
on this side. When recognized, please come to the podium, state your name
for the record, and the council members will listen but
will not engage in discussion during public comment. Disruptive behavior, personal attacks,
or comments about individual city employers is not permitted.
We'll come back to that because I'm starting public comment.
The public hearing items are— lastly, the public comment period
is for items not assigned associated with public hearing. If your comment relates to a
public hearing item, please wait until that item is called. The public hearing for tonight's
meetings is item 15A, which is a resolution
approving the second amendment to the annual budget, and then
17A, which is the ordinance of Eagle Mountain amending the
code section 15.95, um, with the WUI
map. So the time is 7:17.
And I will now open the public comment period. Lacey.
We had one that came through the email today from Joy Rasmussen
who said, I am concerned about the water and sewer bonds because the city already
passed ongoing rate increases last year. Citizens cannot afford more
rate increases beyond what's already been passed. If there is any— if
there is a way to guarantee that these bonds will not result in extra rate
increase beyond the ones already approved last year, that would ease my concerns. Concerns that
of, and that of other citizens. Also, I ask that the
city pass a law to help stop further data centers from being approved to build
in our city. I read that 5 more have been approved. I think that's enough
given their energy, land, and water demands, plus the noise level
they will cause. Thank you. And then we
have one here, um, Tony Castillo,
and he requested that I hand this over to City Council
So what's being passed out is actually the
document that was attached to our
HOA, which is the Overland Trails Phase 3A.
Um, our HOA was basically
formed strictly to maintain
a city street, the alleyways.
So originally, the homes that are part
of 3A, our garages were supposed to be into
the alleyway, but there was some concessions and deals made where
instead of the alleyway, we now have our garages on
the public street. In return, the builder was
made to form an HOA,
and said HOA has to maintain and insure a
city public street. And we just feel like we've been having this issue for years,
and we've been trying to figure out why the heck is this formed. And we
did some research, digging in, digging in, and we found this
from the Planning Commission back in 2006
where it says basically, um, conditions of approval: an HOA
shall be created to strictly enforce the CC&Rs and provide for maintenance of the street.
The HOA shall be responsible for all maintenance and upkeep of the alleyway.
Um, and then we go to another document. I think it's, uh, if you
guys flip it, um, it'll say Big Homes. And I've
highlighted because it says, you know, it deals with The at
the time section 7.7.8 of the Eagle Mountain Development Code.
I tried to find it and couldn't find it anymore, but back then
you know that's where how it was meant to be was in
terms of garage access or alleyways. But a small street
in the rear of the lots has been dedicated to the city, and then you
go back down to number three: An HOA will be formed to enforce these CCNRs
and provide for maintenance of the city.
street. The current plat approval does not require neither the creation
of an H-way nor the maintenance of the other open space found
on the plat. So like I said, there's 28 homes and we're,
we're just frustrated because we're paying this monthly fee and we get
nothing other than the
privilege of ensuring your city street and maintaining said city street.
So my challenge to the city council is How do
we get this resolved? Because we're, as an HOA, we're looking at all avenues to
get out from this agreement that was formed. So I
know you guys can't make a comment, but would love to get this on an
agenda down the road and hear you guys' responses on
it as well. So thank you for your time.
30 seconds remaining. Just, I just wanted to make
sure that Marcus, when we do address this, The— it was kind of presented backwards,
but the Big Homes agreement was June of 2006.
The approval from the city was August. So the
prior one's not the approval. The second
one, but in this case. So— Okay,
I mean, I don't have it in front of me, but— Yeah, so when we
look into it, and you can have my copy or we can send one down
there.
Just— You are the only participant in the meeting. Let us know if there's
anything we need to do. So, Lacey,
that's it? Okay, then at this time
it is 7:22 and we'll close the public comment
period. And before we go on, I want to circle back to Mr.
Fossum. And we saw the rest of the crew came in, so since
they're here for a specific reason, let's bring them up.
You guys might as well come up. You're going to get called anyway.
We all got to come
up too? Yeah, come on up.
So you guys are 252 today, right? Yep.
All right. So they're out of ranches. Yeah. You're not
normally there. No, he's normally there. So this
is the crew out of the ranches. We have a couple that are on vacation
or trades, and so this is the crew that
is covering them. You're normally there, right? Okay,
so we've got 2 of the 4 that are normally here, but we'll
go ahead and introduce them. And so Captain Ascardi, Matt Ascardi,
just recently promoted Yep, 6 months ago. Oh,
he's still on probation, so he can't say anything sideways, which is— No,
I'm done. Oh man, gosh. We're in for
a world of hurt. So Matt Ascardi is,
like mentioned, newly promoted, and usually when you're newly promoted, you're out
on the rove and covering different stations across all of UFA. And Henry
Hunter is the engineer, then Renee Soriano, right?
Yeah, and then Curtis Watkins. And you are a
resident of Eagle Mountain currently, right? Yes, I am. Yeah, so Tony
is also a resident. And so we've got 2 of the 4 that are residents
here and the other 2 are out and about. We're residents for 2
days. Yeah, residents while they cover the citizens of Eagle Mountain.
So with that, I don't know if you had anything else from the
group, but they were just clearing a call, which is why they bumped over.
Do you have any questions for the group? Yeah, they just missed the
standing ovation, so we're gonna do it again. Thank you. Thank you.
So, oh, keep them coming. Keep them coming. You steal
the show. We already
did the standing ovation. Yeah, we're good. We're good.
You know, we figured they thought
that they were getting out of this by showing up, you know, comfortably late.
But so you're on the IMO tonight, right? Yes,
sir. So, okay, if you'll go ahead and introduce yourselves.
They're both part of the Mid-Valley crew as
well with 253, with Captain Wayman,
who's apparently not in here right now. So if you'll just
tell us your names. I'm paramedic Chris James.
Perfect. Hi, I am firefighter
Nicole Snelson. Do you guys live in Eagle Mountain? No, I live
in Pleasant Grove. Okay. Some do, some don't. But you are tied
to 253 regularly, right? Yes. You're on the crew? Yeah. Yeah, this is
our regular crew. So this is— they are normally at 253. So 253
has their whole crew here, and that's a first in a long time apparently.
So between vacations and sick and everything else that
happens, they rotate in and out pretty frequently. So we've got a
crew whole, which is awesome. And then as the other ones come in for,
you know, when they're off vacation, we'll bring them up and reintroduce.
And I think we're good with standing ovations. I don't think we need
one every time. Thank you guys. And just
anything the council wishes to address on that?
Okay. On behalf of the body, I'll just say
that we appreciate your guys' service in keeping us safe and taking
care of our residents. So thank you very much.
All right, back to item number 10 is time
that's been set aside for council to make comments.
So we'll start with Councilmember Clark.
Thank you, Mayor. Um, it's awesome to have so many of our first
responders here. My dad was a firefighter when I was a little girl, so I
have a special place in my heart for all of you guys. Thank you for
all that you do, and thank you to your families because I know it's a
huge sacrifice as well. Um, and I'm grateful to have so many residents here
to just kind of share their thoughts about things that are going on in the
city, and we're grateful when you bring things to our attention.
We as a city are growing and
changing, and there's lots of things that we have on our agenda.
And sometimes it gets really, really confusing and scary when you
see something that says this is going to be $200 million or
$220 million or has the potential to be those things.
So the thing that I would ask is, as you start to
see these things and posts that people put up. If you have questions, reach out
to us. All of our contact info is on the city website. We're happy to
answer some of the questions and the things that we're thinking about with it,
and we're even more happy to receive your guys's feedback when it
comes to items like the things that we have on our agenda. So thank
you all for being here.
Welcome and thank you to our first responders and our second responders.
You guys will get to decide who's who. I'm not going to enter into that
fight. I'm just glad you're all here. Just express my
gratitude to the citizens of Eagle Mountain for the opportunity to sit in this seat
and to listen, to hear, and to make decisions
on your behalf. And I would just reiterate what Councilmember Clark
said. Our phone numbers are published on the website. We're pretty much— we
cannot escape your input, and we don't want to. We need it and
want it. So please reach out to us and ask us questions. To have
a conversation one-on-one is so much more beneficial in my mind than it is
to throw innuendo and wonder and
make supposition. When you really take the time to engage
with one of us, you'll find that we're not quite the noobs that you think
we are. At least I hope that's what you find. Or you may find that
we are the noobs that you think we are. at least have some background
and some understanding that perhaps you haven't been allowed to hear or see. And we're
happy to help you understand what we see and what we're concerned
about. Eagle Mountain is the best city in the state of Utah. There's no question
about that. So I'm sorry for those of you that don't live here. But Councilmember
Clark told me just to remind you that we do have a mortgage assistance program
for first responders. So the more of you that want to come live out here,
you know, you don't have to work. You don't necessarily have to be You could
be here every day, but you could come and live with us as well,
and we invite you to do that. So thank you to the mayor and the
council members for their, their hard work, and for our staff, and for all that
they do to help us enjoy the measure of success that we do.
It's interesting, I had some thoughts prepared, and, uh,
these prior 2 council members already shared some of what I was about to share.
So I'm just going to reiterate this, that there's a principle
in life that Stephen Covey taught about seeking first to understand before seeking to be
understood. And sitting now in this chair where I was sitting
in that chair just a few weeks ago and having
spent numerous hours already serving in this capacity,
meeting with different entities that
are— that have interests here in the city, whether it's developers or landowners,
businesses. Doing— going through that process helps provide a
more understanding, and then that helps hopefully
sharpen the decisions that we make. And it's just interesting when I, you know,
occasionally will look on Facebook and see comments from citizens.
It's evident when some citizens
talk and they don't have all the details on the table. And so I echo
the sentiments of Councilmember Clark and Councilmember Wright that If you have
a concern about something that's so significant that you're ready to lead others in a
cause about it, come talk first and see what information we have. You may
still feel that your position is right and you should still have a voice and
lead people against something that you feel is not correct.
But I would encourage coming and actually getting as many details as possible before
trying to lead others down a certain pathway. You might
be surprised about the details and information that you'll learn in that process that
may change the way you approach things. And I'll tell you that sitting
in this chair has given me a lot of additional perspective I didn't have previously.
And I comment to my wife, I say,
you know, it's interesting when you try to judge
what a puzzle is when you don't have all the puzzle pieces to look at.
And as sitting in this perspective here, gives us some
additional puzzle pieces. You also bring additional puzzle pieces that we
may not have, and it's really critical for us to hear from what your perspective
is and what you're experiencing. So we definitely need to hear from you.
We have our own perspectives we bring, but we need to hear yours as well.
And we will have a more— a stronger city if
we can collaborate one with another and in
a respectful fashion where we get as much information from each other as possible
instead of trying to voice a viewpoint without having heard the other side just
yet. That's an important principle in life and something I teach in
my company. I teach the values of love, serve,
connect, and transform as some of the more important
principles that you can follow to have a successful organization. It's challenging
for us to connect as citizens when we're not willing to
listen to one another first before vocalizing our own opinion.
And so it's my hope that we can remember those principles, and I'm saying this
to myself as well, to remember these principles, that we can
listen to others first and seek to hear their viewpoints
before trying to vocalize our own.
Yeah, I just want to echo everything that was said previously. One of the quotes
that has been coming to mind to me recently is, if you If
you want a smaller government, you need a bigger people.
And when I first heard that, I thought, okay, that means I need to lift
where I'm where I'm standing in my own community. So I love
when citizens come and they bring things like this. You know,
they're digging through 2006 Planning Commission
notes to figure out how how was my HOA formed? What are the next steps
that I can take? I joked earlier in our working
session that if you remember the movie
Field of Dreams, there's this line, if you build
it, they will come. And in Eagle Mountain, we all came, and now we're
trying to build it. We're trying to get the infrastructure and the roads and,
you know, the proper staffing and all of those things. So we're
playing a lot of catch-up. And, you know, as Councilmember
Whiting said, I'm sorry. You're— you kind of see the top part of the iceberg,
and once you get into this role, you are learning about the other 90%
that's just not obvious. So I
appreciate the opportunity to serve and look forward
to our discussion today. Thank you, Mayor. Yep,
thanks guys. And I just want to add my appreciation.
Definitely talking about different roles, when I
stepped into this seat It's a little bit different than what
I'm used to, and especially thanks to our first and second responders. And we'll
let you arm wrestle that, but we'll decide who wins at the rodeo and the
goat tying or whatever, right? So,
but definitely thanks. And in this role, I get to kind of get in the
trenches a little bit more and spend a lot of time with both staff and,
and all of our department heads and whatnot. It's a pleasure to be in the
trench doing the heavy lifting with, with you guys. And all of our staff members.
It's been an honor. So just want to add my gratitude
and thanks to as well the council who put up with me and take my
calls all the time to try to get through some of this lift
that we have in front of us. So let's get right to it.
We talked about the consent agenda in our
work session. So if there— are there any questions? If not,
I'll entertain a motion. Motion to approve the consent agenda, Mayor.
Second. We have a motion by Council Member Wright and a second by Council Member
Huish to approve this consent agenda, and we'll start the vote with Council Member Wright.
Yes. Council Member Whiting. Yes. And Council Member
Huish. Yes. Council Member Clark. Yes.
Okay. The first item
on our agenda,
We were going to come back to this discussion, right?
I can't remember where we got on this because we talked about it in the—
yeah, 14A is the discussion of the Fifth Amendment to the Overland Master
Development Agreement.
Marcus, did you have anything on that?
Yes. So this would be the Fifth Amendment to the
amended and restated Master Development Agreement for Overland.
This relates to to a commercial development in a portion that has been previously
designated as commercial. For the development,
it would encompass approximately 53 acres of
land and would include a Smith's Marketplace and a
Lowe's, among numerous pad sites included in the development.
As far as trying to compress a,
you know, 20-page agreement with 60 pages
of exhibits into a brief presentation. I would say
that the highlights of it are it does include incentives.
Right now we're still in a draft phase and there's some stuff going
back and forth, but right now what was given to you relates
to $8 million in incentives. What we talked about in Planning
Commission when they heard this matter And, you know,
I'll reiterate it here, is that there's also certain money
that has been— that was given to us by Utah County
in relation to the construction of Airport Road, and they are
wanting us to use that for this particular segment that abuts the development.
This development— let me back up— is located between Midvalley Road
and Airport Road east of Pony Express Parkway.
Yes. From, I guess, kitty-corner from Quarry Ride and
across from Frontier Middle School.
So that's the location of it.
So yeah, so I think the total incentives would be
$10.27 million that are being sought at this point.
And this is to support the infrastructure for the development. It would go to roads,
sewer lines, water lines, that kind of thing to support the development. Right. In order
to enable Smith's to move forward in developing this
property as a commercial development.
It already has, like I said, it already has vested historic commercial zoning.
So, I mean, this is consistent with what was anticipated
here for many years under the Overland Master Development Agreement. And this would be just
putting a specific development in place for that.
Let me see. Yeah, there's, as far as there's certain
exceptions to code that they're looking for, I think the highlight, the one that we
talked about most in Planning Commission I wanted to highlight is they're asking
to allow for additional lighting above what we would allow under
code. So right now our code says you can have up to 100,000 lumens per
net acre, and they are asking for 150,000.
per gross acre. So it's a significant amount of additional lighting,
and I'll let them explain the commercial justification for that.
But that— I think those are the highlights of the agreement, and I'm more
than happy to answer questions about specifics.
Okay. And I know— I think I talked to you about— Councilmember Herjus
about the lighting and encouraged you to go look at Walmart, so you might have
some stuff on that. Are there specific questions
right now before we bring up the applicant, or you want to comment on that?
On the lighting, I did take your advice. I drove to Walmart,
stood in the middle of the parking lot at 10 o'clock at night and
looked up, and I could see stars. I then drove to the Smith's in
Saratoga Springs, same exercise, and I could see stars.
I think the difference is just how much of that light do you capture the
way that the lights are built. If you go to the Walmart in Saratoga Springs,
Springs, the cones release a ton of light. In Saratoga
Springs, they have these flat surface
tops and the light projects down on the parking lot versus letting
it escape upward. So if
the lumens go up, that's something that I kind of look for, is to make
sure that we're pointing them directionally down and not letting it escape up,
up into the— But through that
exercise, you felt more comfortable with the Ask at least.
I could see stars from the parking lot at Smith's in Saratoga Springs.
I'd encourage people to do that.
Okay, go ahead. I think maybe this is a question for Mr.
Draper. In the code where the dark
skies stuff is, in Section D of 17.56.05,
it talks about the total outdoor light output should
not Shall not exceed the 100,000 lumens, but then it also immediately
after that sentence says this cap is not intended to be
achieved in all cases or as a design goal. Instead,
design goals should be the lowest levels of lumens necessary to meet the
lighting requirements of the site. And I think that
sentence in there is telling us that when safety
is called for and some of the other things so that they can function in
the space. space, that the human element of City Council should be looking
at the number of lumens allowed and what's a part of
the plan. Does that sentence mean anything different when you look at that?
Well, let me, uh, let me find that and read that. Sorry. And while he's
doing that, I just wanted to say, if it, if it is a question of
safety, I don't mind if we need to I'm gonna ask our Chief Knutson to
come up and give us some kind of, any kind of— You are
the only participant in the meeting. No, there's a lot of people here.
Yeah, so, I mean, my understanding is based
on the Planning Commission discussion was that is the basic rationale
is in relation to safety for the customers there, whether they're
going to one of the gas stations that would be part of the development or
You know, frequenting one of the many pad sites or one of the main anchors.
It's a safety issue is kind of what was conveyed during that meeting.
And again, they can explain more deeply as to why that is.
I would, you know, as far as an answer to your question, Councilmember Clark,
I would say that, yeah, I mean, it does give us some wiggle room,
but, you know, that it's in the development agreement, so that would make it very
clear that they would be able to exceed that cap if that's approved. Got it.
I just think that it's important when we talk about it that it's not like
they're breaking code when in reality code says that
it's not intended to always be just that cap.
So I thought that was a good thing for us to draw attention to.
And did you need to address the safety issue with our Sheriff's Department or anything,
or do you think— No, because I also I have done
the exercise of going to Smith's at 10 PM and Walmart at 10 PM,
and I know there's definitely a difference. And,
um, I think that every effort will be
made to make sure that we keep the nature of Eagle Mountain, but safety
is also important for the nature of Eagle Mountain too.
Is, is there anything required in the MDA that would require
for the light to point downward versus escaping
upward? I mean, they're required to comply with our dark
skies ordinance. This would be just kind of clarifying they could go up to 150,000
lumens, but otherwise the ordinance would apply. Okay, thank you.
Any other questions before we bring up the applicant?
And if— and Kyle or Brad or who's leading?
Okay, yeah, go ahead.
Yeah, push the button there for the mic to come on. Thank you.
Kyle Zanti with Smith Food and Drug. And Jeff Randall with AWA Consulting.
We also just want to thank Mayor and Council and Ben
for letting us speak tonight and discussing this project.
We're excited to potentially be a part of this community.
We've worked on this for the better part of 2 and a half years now
with your staff, and what an incredible group.
Wouldn't spend it with anyone else and wouldn't fight the
traffic to get here for any other city other than Eagle Mountain.
Evan, from the very beginning, I think has been a great— Here's
to Evan. That's right. Evan's been a great advocate,
I think, for you guys. And I think really pushed
to at least get us to the table.
And I think once we did take the time to
come out here, I think we were very, very excited
and very pleased to potentially do a store
here in this community. So I think, Jeff,
if there's anything you want to say, I think we're ready for questions, or do
you want us to sit back down? Yeah, we can just answer questions. On the
lighting question, I know, uh, Council Member Huish,
we talked a little earlier and you brought up some of those questions. Um,
all of the light fixtures will be— they're called cutoff. That, that lens
you're talking about, it's a cutoff lens, so it doesn't allow any light up,
it forces it all down. Um, so all of our light
poles, uh, the lights that are on the building, which are called wall packs,
all of those will have those cutoff lens to meet that dark ordinance that Marcus
is talking about. And then on the lumens level,
we've gone back and Kyle and I were going through this earlier today. We've kind
of tried to study some of our stores, dial in where's
our light levels at. One area that
I'd say increases the light levels is our fuel center canopies are
very bright. bright, as kind
of typical in the, in the fuel world. And when we subtract
that out, it brings us down. So we're looking at where we can be there.
We're— we definitely can come down from 150.
I think there's some more, some room in there. We can run through some numbers
and figure out where we're at, but I think we do have some room there
to kind of bring those— so the, the main parking fields, the main areas,
the big, the big areas you I think you get pretty close to that 100,000
number. So we might have areas like the canopy, the fuel center canopy,
that's brighter, but the rest of the area will be pretty close. So we'll
work through those numbers with you and be able to get you some more
information there. One of
the things that— and I just want to make sure that it's on your radar
and that staff's aware that this is kind of our desire— within our code
there's very specific specific— I don't know what it's called. It's where
the light comes down under a fuel canopy and can reflect back
up, and how much that is. It's different than all the
rest because of fuel canopies. I just want to make sure that every
effort is made to follow that part
of the code because it does contribute a lot of light.
Um, I'm like— You're talking kind of like the reflectiveness?
Under the canopy? Yes, yes, yes, yes. Let's see,
there's a whole section about it for,
um, under fuel canopies, and I'm trying to find it. Okay, we can look at
that. But yeah, but that— I think that's an important piece because
if we're taking that number out of the net number, then let's
for sure make sure that we're following the code for the fuel canopy
area. Yeah, makes sense. Okay, we'll take a look at that.
Gentlemen, welcome. So in 3.2 of the agreement,
it talks about some additional permitted uses that are
outside of what the vesting from the 2017 ordinances
give. And specifically, the ones that I'm interested
in hearing you speak to a little bit are the commercial laundries and outdoor storage.
What's your intent with those 2 uses? So outdoor storage,
there is an outdoor storage plan, if I remember right, as some of the exhibits
in there. For example, Lowe's has outdoors— like,
they've got their outdoor garden center, their sheds, the different things
that they do. Smith's doesn't have nearly as much outdoor
storage. Occasionally we might have a fireworks stand.
Christmas trees. Christmas trees, seasonal, seasonal display,
more type stuff. So that's the outdoor storage component,
and there's some exhibits in that document that kind of identify those areas of
where we would maybe want to do those. Commercial laundries,
I don't think we have any intent of that at this point. Is there a
reason that you need that? That's my question, because typically they introduce chemicals into
the storm system. And yeah, I'm just curious if there's an actual need for
that or if we could remove it. We could look at that one and talk
with our leasing group and see if there's anything there that we see coming or
anything there. We can take a look at that one for For sure, Councilmember Wright.
And then I just, yeah, I think my question was answered
earlier on this one. Several of the lighting you
talked to.
Acceleration lanes. Well, there's still a couple of things in there.
It's like one of the things in 6.31, and I guess I can
get there and we can talk about the roads too. But in 6.31,
I'm just, I'm a little anxious
about this portion of the agreement for a reason.
I trust our city engineer. I love our city engineer. I don't have any issue
with my city engineer. So I want to start there. I'll look over that direction.
The concern that I have is just making sure that
we have checks and balances in releasing any escrow that might come out of there.
I've just seen some issues with that in other circumstances.
And so I'd like to see that be tightened up a little bit, Mayor.
That would be my suggestion is that, you know, to release that, it's got to
be at least 2 people. And I think you ought to be one of them
and perhaps the city manager. The 2 of you ought to review that after the
engineer gives you some sort of a, you know, a recommendation.
But I'm uncomfortable with that just being any one person.
Doesn't matter if it's city engineer or the treasurer. Would you be fair To make
it 3 or at least include Marcus? Yeah. I don't care whether or
not I'm included, but I'm fine with just putting in
the language for those specific people. I don't know that they care as much.
No, yeah, if it's city engineer and mayor or city engineer— I
think they want it just done administratively. I think that's what they're asking. Yes.
And I totally agree with the checks and balances side of things. That makes a
lot of sense. Definitely. I mean, if we're going to be taking money out of
it, I want to make sure that— Yeah. That it's been approved
through a number of checks and balances, let me say it that way. And then
regarding traffic flow, you know, just— can I see the map?
Just when I look at it and I look at kind of what you guys
are looking to do for the main entrance on Pony Express Parkway,
I want to understand that a little bit because I'm having a hard time— I'm
having a hard time envisioning how that traffic runs, and I hate to see that
light stop the traffic on Pony Express that's headed south.
So, okay, visual. That's what we talked about, Mayor, on Friday. Okay,
so yeah, Mayor and Kyle and I talked about this on Friday a
little bit, and, and there's a signal design
called a high-T signal, um,
that I thought Mayor had a great idea with this. We, we've, uh, I've talked
to our traffic engineer and he's rerunning kind of the simulation and the We're
looking at some of that modeling to see how that'll work. We would need an
acceleration lane coming out, so like the left-outs would have to have an acceleration lane
then to merge into the oncoming traffic. So we're looking through some of that
modeling and the dimensions it'll take,
but we are looking at that for sure. You hit on the very next thing
I was going to ask you about, is just some acceleration lanes out of some
of those, and in that one in particular. Okay. I mean, you have 1,
2, 3, 4, 5 entrances, and I
think 4 of them have a decel. Well, no, they all have it. They all—
I think they, I think they, uh, they all have decels. They don't have the
acceleration. I just wonder how much trouble it'd be to put an acceleration lane in
those so that we get people coming out and then they can merge into traffic.
I, I know that may add a little expense, but I think that it
also adds an element of safety and better traffic circulation in that area
in particular. So that's, that's one of my asks. Uh,
and then I'll, I'll defer to my councilman friends at this point in
time. Okay. And maybe something else will come up, but— We can take a look
at that. I know, and I know we had a chance to talk prior,
so I don't want to reiterate too many things, but just so
the public can hear some of the commentary as well, uh, one of the concerns
we had talked about, uh, was the left
turn, the, the queuing lanes for turning left.
I'm just— I mean, I ran into issues with that on Redwood Road trying
to turn into Smith's, actually, you know. And so I
think making sure that those queuing lanes would be long enough to allow
for those left turns to occur,
I think that was one of the issues that I— at least on the traffic.
You've touched on the other ones already, Councilmember Wright. And then I just wanted to
touch on the We talked about architectural design.
And just a few notes, just for the public.
So the location of this is right next to where the
downtown would be. And we do have a higher set of standards for
the downtown architecture. And because we're trying to create
a sense of place that is unique and powerful,
magnetic, inspiring,
and given the location of this being right next to— Downtown. to the
downtown. And given that this is really a collaborative
project that also involves some land that city-owned currently,
and I feel like the city can come in and say, we do want
to have higher levels of architectural standards. I think
you'd mentioned in the— just when we were together that pad sites,
it's easier for that to occur. Is that— am I right in saying that?
Correct, yep. those, and I know those are prominent, more prominent right across
Pony Express. Mm-hmm. I think that would be absolutely
essential to have those stand out.
And also, for me, I really still want,
you know, the Lowe's, the Smith's, I still want those to be— to
have the higher architectural standards. It's a one-time opportunity.
And if Smith's were coming in anywhere, pretty much anywhere else in the city,
You know, I wouldn't be as concerned about this. But when it's right
here, that's— it's something for me
to feel comfortable moving forward. I really feel like that architectural— additional
architectural detail and element that makes it prolific needs to
be involved. And just— it's really going to be— it's going
to be, I could probably say, close to a nonstarter if we can't get to
something like that. Because, you know, It's because of where it's at located right next
to the downtown. And I really appreciate, you know,
seeing what you could do with that. I really appreciate that the traffic's going to
be very challenging right here. And I recognize there's a
commercial zone already. And so there's something that will be
here that needs to be commercial. So I'm not disputing that.
But there's some impacts that are at play here too.
And trying to manage that, mitigate, mitigate the traffic issues as much as
possible. So, uh, very appreciative of that as well. Okay,
that's— yeah, appreciate that. Yeah, we're happy to look into that, Craig. I think we
want to build something the city's proud of, you know. If we're going to build
something that's hopefully here the next 100 years, you know, we want to
be able to be like, that's my Smith's. So we're with you.
Yeah, that's awesome. I, I love that mentality, and that's how Hopefully we're
thinking about all of these decisions. I can't tell you how many thousands of dollars
I've spent at the Home Depot in American Fork 20 years ago,
and now it's all going to Saratoga. We're excited to— Bring it
to Eagle Mountain. Yeah, we're excited for the economic activity and commercial— We talked about
leakage, right? We want to stop the leakage that's happening to the inner city.
That's right. And it brings that economic growth back into the city. It relieves the
citizens from a lot of the tax burdens. So we're really excited for this project.
I think we kind of addressed the lumens issue. We've talked about the
ingress/egress out of the project. And I
would just echo Councilmember Whiting's comments on just the—
it doesn't have to be Park City. I know I said that earlier today.
I didn't want to, like, scare you away. But it
does need to kind of have an Eagle Mountain theme. And, you know, the Pony
Express Trail used to go right through this city, and, and you're just parked
right in the middle of 3 major routes. So would love to see
that, you know, that, that signature, that Eagle Mountain signature on
the, on the face of the buildings. So that's all I had to add.
Okay, did we cover it all up here? Any last comments?
No, we really appreciate it. It's good feedback. We'll take this kind of into account
and work with We're working with Marcus closely on this and look
forward to coming back and bringing back the final product and working through this final
agreement with you. So,
okay. Okay. If I could just add one more.
Yes. Because I know Councilmember Wood's not here, and I don't want to speak publicly
for him, but I do feel like I just— in the conversations that I've
had with him, he also echoes a lot of the sentiments that have been talked
about. There's also concerns about the TIF financing that's that's being
included in this. You know, Eagle Mountain is is growing. I mean,
there time once was where we we had to give a lot of incentives for
people to come. The city's grown to a healthy level, and it's going to continue
to grow very quickly. And I think I I I I don't
want at least this item to have passed through the meeting thinking okay,
the TIF's all good. I still think that's for discussion. It's something
we got to still think about and ponder about. And I know that Councilmember.
Mr. Wood would have at least expressed that when he was here.
Sure, sure, we appreciate it. And we're, uh, we'll, we'll reach
out to him as well to get any feedback from him here in
the following days as well. So I want to ask just one final
question, and I may ask this of Brad. Um, Brad, do you have any concerns
with the sewer, water drainage, any of those things?
PRV valves, we're good? Okay, you've been through all that? Okay,
thank you.
Okay, thank you very much. Yep, and that was just a discussion item,
so there's no action needed, but thanks for coming, guys.
Thank you, guys. Good night. All right,
the next item is a public hearing. It's 15A, a resolution
of Eagle Mountain City approving the second amendment to the fiscal year 2025-2026
annual budget. And this one, we're going
to invite Kimberly to come make the
presentation.
Thank you, Mayor and Council. While I pull this up, just want to give a
quick plug for our Citizen Academy. Those applications
are open and available. I love finance. If anybody else
wants to learn to love finance, sign up for the Citizen Academy and
come and learn about all the great things that not only finance does, but all
the other amazing departments in our city. So we hope
to fill that up just like we have with all the others. So.
Okay, so this is our second amendment,
and I'm really grateful we're halfway through the fiscal year with this.
One of the things that we like to do as we start to look at
it is we are looking to see how we fared through the first 6 months
and we reevaluate our revenue projections. It gives us an opportunity
to see if there is any additional funding resources for some of
those initiatives that we didn't have the resources for and were not originally approved
in the budget. That is one of the things that we look at during these
mid-year amendments as well as just any
other needs needs that might have come up during this year in this process that
we have. So with this particular amendment
that we have, then we are looking to increase the overall
city budget so it would go to $163 million with
the changes that we'll touch on within these different funds. But right now, primarily we're
looking at within the general fund and then our special
revenue, our enterprise funds, and our capital project related
funds are the ones that we have changes that are being affected or proposed tonight
with this particular amendment. So in the general fund,
one of the things, again, because it's just a— it's a newer time, so I
like to take a chance to explain and talk a little bit about
with some of the funding that we're doing here. We need
to make sure that we're maintaining a balanced budget. So with the asks
that we have here, and it's showing that the overall general fund increase
is this $1.7 million. All of that is not an actual outflow
of resources, but because we have to maintain the balanced budget with
the additional revenue growth that we're expecting, that beyond what we're
asking to spend will be rolled over into fund balance, and it has
to be an appropriation, which shows up as an expenditure item. So we'll talk a
little bit about that as we come along the way. But particularly, we do have
a request for one additional FTE in our building department for an additional
inspector that we have. With the requests
related to this, this is the location, the area where the revenues are
coming in. So, Council, you guys will remember we talked a little bit about revenue
when we had our budget and planning retreat in regards to that.
As far as our tax dollars and those particular things,
we're on target with budget. We don't actually project that we'll have additional
revenue growth this year in relation to those. But the area that we do
have is related to those building and community development related fees.
Now the primary reason again that drives that is when we do
have some of these larger commercial or development related projects,
those fees come in, they come in this one-time year,
but we're providing services over a 2-year period for inspections
and so forth. And so there, it's not
uncommon again that what you see is an influx of money that you are seeing
up front, but the demands for that is going to come over time and
will be spent down. So this particular item
here, again, it is being funded with resources that would be generated
within this year, and it is primarily needed
for those commercial-related projects and resources
that we have. Some of the additional
highlighted items within the general fund that we are looking at is to
replenish the road maintenance funds.
We did have that unexpected project this year related to the settling of the
road there on Point Express Parkway across from the Silver Lake Park.
And so adding these funds back into it allows us to do the original planned
maintenance as well. And with this particular item, we do also
have reserved funds that are available specific to roads that
would account for that. We're asking for some additional
professional services that we have needs for that will be within our Human Resource
Division, Engineering, as well as
Economic Development. And let me— there was one other division
that I can't— I can't see my notes. Usually it has like my notes
there. So, but with the America 250 as well. So as
you guys know, this is the anniversary here for our America 250.
as well as the Eagle Mountain 30th anniversary celebration.
With that, this budget amendment does include some funding resources,
but those would be used more towards the lines of being able to purchase
merchandise that is specially logoed related to this that then can also
be available for resale for the community. It would be
being able to help fund the time capsule
that we have been discussing to have for the city that would be set
aside for that. And just making sure that we can highlight
and take advantage of this great year that is ahead of us in
regards to the celebrating of our community and our nation as a whole.
The surveying for the property disposal, this is related
to the council's continued efforts to try to clean
up some of those encroachment items that we have. Now,
long-term, we do expect these to be replenished through the
sale of that land. So as individuals choose to purchase that, right now
the ones we've done so far have been where the purchase will take place
at a later time. It's more of like a deed restriction that
when they sell the property, that would take place. So we don't have those funds
that are being replenished, but we do want to be able to continue with this
particular program. project to clean those up.
Um, and then, um, some evidence storage lockers for,
um, our Sheriff's Department is an expansion need.
So of those items there, those are all considered what we would say is a
one-time funding item where we are looking to use resources that are
on hand. They're not going— ongoing operational costs that we have,
um, and don't require continued revenue commitments beyond the current
fiscal year, which is the reason that they are being recommended at this time.
I touched just a little bit on the general fund side in regards to the
fund balance and the money that we are looking at. Even though
we have this projected revenue growth of an additional $1.7
million, those funds are coming in from a resource that are
restricted, and so they will be able to be used to cover
the costs related to the request for the one-time FTE
and those increases there on that building division side.
But the other items that we talked about from a one-time nature,
then we are looking at the use of fund balance within the general fund.
So there are the road portion that we talked about, and then
there, with some of those professional services, it is related to
some engineering costs to do some studies related to roads.
So that $575,000 would come from
fund balance, but it is coming from a restricted source. So it doesn't
reduce the maximum fund balance we can have. It's actually
drawing down on those resources that are restricted specifically
for road purposes. And then that remaining $300,000
is the portion of those one-time costs that in order to fund
them would require us to use Part of the fund balance reserves that
we have. Dipping into that and pulling it down would draw those reserves
down by about 0.5% is where we would be with that
for this year. Is there any questions about that before I flip
on? Okay. Okay. So then with
our enterprise funds, we call them enterprise funds. Those are our business-type activities,
the water, wastewater, and so forth. So we have a project
that's already been underway. It's our tertiary treatment project
that actually retreats wastewater that can then be
used for secondary water on outdoor irrigation purposes.
That particular project, we received grant funding from the state
as well as at the county level, and then some matching funds and stuff from
the city. So this is rolling forward some of those project funds
because the project is still ongoing and it's not completed at this time, and that
it also accounts for a, um, a transfer.
Um, we had a $1 million commitment from our wastewater impact fee funds,
and so that money will come over to the wastewater fund, um, to meet that
match requirement that we had and for them to be able to finish this project
down. So,
um, on our capital project, um,
location, we We have had a couple of council meetings,
I believe, where we've had some discussions with the council regarding the
eagle monument, about having it be reinstalled,
as well as having the wall in
that area rebuilt and restructured for that. And then adding
an additional digital display that would be in the quarry ride area that
provides that same information to residents that you
can see from the Silver Lake area
where the Silver Lake Park is, and then off the freeway, off Pony Express Parkway
where it turns onto SR 73, we have another message board.
So this brings us a message board that is downtown in the city center
area. And in the past, what we've done when we've had events or things like
that is we've had to pull in that mobile trailer and put the sign up
for, for providing and communicating that type of
information. So this would just create, again, a more permanent visible option for our
residents as they come through this area to receive that communication.
And with these 2 particular items, then the recommendation on the funding source
would be to use some of the utility sale proceeds that we have on hand.
And we have those funds that are there and
earmarked for public purposes as the council decides. We typically
look at that spending and allocation once a year during the
budget process as we look at capital projects. So we will be having that come
up again here in the next month or so as we work through our budget
planning process for the next year. But that is
a source and the location that we are recommending to fund those 2 particular projects
there. Then the Mid-Valley Highway
Phase 2 study, as well as the design for the traffic signal
at Trailhead and Pony Express. The reasons that these ones show up now in the
capital project and not just in the engineering budget within the general fund is
because they are at a level that they will become— it's
a beginning phase of an actual capital project that we have.
So the design for the Trailhead-Pony Express intersection,
we have funded already in this year to start the design,
but originally it was just that we would need a traffic signal. But again,
with all the changes that have occurred, if you'll recall, that is
the one that's right outside of City Hall. It will have to be a reconstruction
of that intersection because we have medians on both sides,
roundabouts, I guess it would be, on both sides of those. So this will
add some additional funding so we can get started on that design process as
well. And then the guardrail on Pony Express. So this
was one that the council actually approved at a appropriated last
year, but we didn't get started on it. It was utilizing some
of the resources that were left over as we looked at that emergency egress
area off of the Lone Tree. And so at that time,
the council had said and identified that those sources would be—
could be used for the same item here, but it's not
actually in the budget to be spent. And so this just cleans that up
for us since we didn't get it in before June 30th of last year.
So that accounts for our capital project items. I'm gonna click to
the next one, but I just wanna check and see if you have any questions
on that before we do.
Questions on the capital project fund? Yeah. The digital
signs, I'm curious what's driving that. Is that
a citizen request or is that more of a— That
one's, that came forward as a staff request.
In terms of, again, anytime we have events,
we're just pulling out the mobile sign construction trailer that
we're trying to use from a communication standpoint. And then people here, that's the
only time they get information. So we just don't have anything placed in City Center
at all in terms of the message board that communicates to residents about
what is taking place. So if you've ever paid attention to the ones
in the 2 locations, it's not just about events. It communicates about our
city council meetings, all kinds of things that are coming up within
the city. But there's just not, again, that location is a very
visible location where people are coming through, which is
why we chose to pick Corey Wright is 'cause we were already having to deal
with the temporary signage that we were constantly putting up when we have events
that are taking place at the Corey Wright Park.
From that point, So, um, okay. Yeah, I just wanted to kind
of better understand if that's citizens that are asking for that communication or if it
was something internally. Because, yeah, internally of an overall objective
and goal, um, from— I guess what we hear from
residents is more methods of communication. So those who aren't on
Facebook or other ways that they can receive and be aware of things,
and this was one of those that we felt might be able to assist in
in both ways. I'll just also add,
it's exactly what Kimberly just said. People always
say like, oh, I wish I would have known about this. Well, I didn't know
about this. Like, that's my biggest like bane of my existence.
And I think it's really important that if we have another
option to get information out to our residents that we seriously look
at it. I hate spending money on stuff like this, but I also think about
the manpower to pull the orange signs out and then return them
and do all of those things. And all of that is adding up too.
And they're woefully inadequate because we have to like
cut words in half and all of the other things. So like to me,
our residents are asking for more information and this is one of the ways that
we can actually make it happen. So I support the digital sign
for this. What, what is the maintenance cost of those signs
each year? So we have like the initial front,
like the digital ones. Mhm. I don't know that I've ever been
told. Oh, here comes Brad. We, we pay a, a small,
um, annual fee that is less than around $2,000 a
year, but it's for our internet connection and stuff to make all of that
happen at all, and that covers the cost at all of Yeah,
most of it's been just the technologies in it that's
been updated. I think most of the wear and tear on them has been—
they've been put together, they were pretty solid when they went together. And from
an aesthetic and a visual aspect and durability, we haven't seen
a lot of issues with them. They've stayed constructed and whatnot. Over time,
we probably— there will probably be some components that we need to replace. And I
think that's a good point. But we haven't had anything significant other than just the
technologies inside of it. Thank you. And this one's going
to be bigger than the 2 existing ones, correct?
Yeah, we got a design, um, to do one that's larger.
Um, I don't think we need to make that decision today,
um, obviously on the size, but, um, I think
the proposal when we measured it out was like double the size
that is there. When talking to the
vendor about options, they come in like 1 by 1 blocks
in like a grid. And so we can essentially grid it to the size that
we want. And so it's really just about getting the
money allocated so that we can start having those discussions to see which direction
we want to go, how big we want to make it, and whatnot. And where
is it going to— sorry. That was my question. Well, on behalf
of Councilmember Wright and myself, Where is it going to be located at the park?
So in quick discussions with the vendor, I mean, I, I think
right on the corner of the park's probably going to be the best place.
By the pickleball area over there. And that's, I mean,
that's our downtown city center, literally. So. And to
be honest, I mean, it's, it's not just because it's a corner, but there's
already some power feed in there and some of those things that are necessary for
them anyway that we can probably utilize and tap into. So that
seems like the best fit, but obviously we'll explore it and look at
it and take recommendations and go from there. How critical
is it that it goes in now versus, say, a year from now?
Um, I don't know that it's, uh, super critical.
Um, it's just, uh, I think long-term,
I think we have enough people that use our park, but by volume just
for our events alone, standalone. And we're, we're a busy
city, and you've all attended the events.
And it's, uh, with all the feedback
that are on those construction signs and whatnot, um,
we hear the same thing. We hear the same feedback that you get as council
members, where we didn't know that this was going on, we didn't
know that's what it was, we didn't know, uh, we didn't know that we could
attend that. We thought that might have been a private— so
I think it'll do good for the city to get information out there for not
only our events to really showcase and say, look, here's some things that are coming
up that you need to be aware of in the city, but today this is
happening. And I mean, I think that our park
has proven and shown itself over the years with the volumes of
people that attend it that It's become our gathering place,
and it is our gathering place. And it's just advocating and showing one
more mechanism to draw people to come and participate in the
community. And Councilmember Whiting, I would I would say this: It's
really frustrating to me to see those utility cell proceeds sitting in
an account. I know they're they're drawing some interest, but those dollars have
been sitting there now for decades, and they're worth a lot
less. than they were when they were first generated. They won't buy what
they would then, and yet we continue to sit on them. And so
from my perspective, I just think they're better to invest in the community and to
get something of value today that will bring some immediate benefit.
So I mean, I'm fully supportive of this. I think this is the right place
to put some of those monies.
One other thing that I think we need to remember is that The other 2
are located in Silver Lake and the ranches, and our
population growth is exploding in City Center, and there's
also homes that have existed here for 30 years. So I think putting
one down here sends a clear message to our residents that use
this part of town that it's important to us that they know what's
going on too. So I would just make the case with that as well.
Thank you. I was just gonna ask, can the
utility sale proceeds be used for other projects like trail connections
within the city, or is it specifically around Corey
Ride? There is— I'm gonna just answer,
make one other comment, and I'll have Kimberly answer that, 'cause I think that they're
general, can be used anywhere at council discretion.
But the biggest complaints that I receive are The fact
that it takes a lot of employee time to go out those out there,
set those up, and then I get complaints from the residents
when it's Friday night or Saturday activity, and we're not taking them
down till Monday or or even Tuesday if it's a three-day holiday or
something of that nature. And so our events are still on the construction signs
sitting out there, and and it just kind of looks tacky as opposed to
a fresh fresh. professional look at our downtown when we're going to have our downtown
across the street. That's, that's the impression that I've gotten and why, why this was
brought up. But I'll turn the answer over to Kimberly on the
use of utility funds. Yeah, so the utility sale proceeds are completely
unrestricted. So they are an item that each year that we
look at with the council to identify if there are particular
projects or things that you'd like to slate them for. So We
have about a little over $5 million still that's available and about—
$500,000, I hope. No, we have about $5 million.
$500, that's it? Yeah, that's right,
$5. That's it. $5 million. $5. Holy cow.
Yeah, so there's about $5 million that is left and
of that, around $3 million of it is still unassigned. So there's about
$2 million of it is assigned towards and committed towards specific things. But each
year, again, if those things aren't moving forward, or depending if they are, we give
the council an opportunity to again reallocate that. We do that same
thing on the cap— So these funds sit within the capital project fund.
So there are other resources that are also
available in the capital project fund, and we look
at those every year as we put together— and actually,
as we put together what we call our 5-year capital improvement plan, where we're
trying to identify what our needs are and the resources, and then to look
at those funds. Thank you. That gives me some good context.
It's not an either/or. I'm— in my head, I'm thinking, like, is this the best
use of what we have? Correct. Yeah. So there,
there is an existing amount of money that needs to
be used over time and— yes, and put it to its highest
and best use. Yes. Okay. And, and, and the big reason that there's still money
left over is because, again, when this money first came in, it was 2014,
2015-ish. But, um,
the council did 100% allocate that out towards
programming and things that they wanted to have happen. Most of
that happened. And then again, over time, um, some things came in
under budget, or some of these items that haven't moved forward just yet,
um, some items that had big ticket things. Then again, over time, it didn't appear
to be a need for the community anymore, and the council unassigned that money.
And so I often like to talk about sometimes
when you have pockets of money, it's just as hard as when you don't have
any money. You want to make sure you're spending it wisely and that you're not
just using it. And this is something that the council has been very sensitive
about when they sold those utility systems, that these were funds
to be able to help further things that the citizens
were asking for a lot with landscaping and improvements
along the roadways and things like that and stuff. So anyway,
okay. Let's switch over.
Okay. When we jump over to our special revenue funds then,
what we have here is— I was
trying to think really quick all of a sudden. So for us, our impact fee
funds get classified as special revenue funds for our
non-business type activities. So we have a project that
is already being in the works related to
the Cory-Wright parking lot. And when the bids came back for that,
it was at an additional cost. And so this budget
amendment would pick up the additional funding that would be needed
to actually do that project. If we choose not to, it means that
we just won't move forward with that project. This is, um, the funding would need
to be appropriated in order for that to move forward. And then, uh, the East
Trunk Line, um, that sewer line design. So this would
be starting the design process for the major trunk line that would run kind
of— I know it's east, but if I were to say it like from
the Lake Mountain Road, not that far up, but you're looking on
that east side down, and then we'll eventually connect in with the wastewater
treatment plant. So where the freeway— is
that what that is? Is a freeway there? Anyway, there's a major road that's going
there, and we need to make sure we're designing the utilities before the roadway comes
because you want to get that installed and stuff as well beforehand.
So I do want to make sure we just have a tiny bit of discussion
about the mortgage assistance program. So the mortgage assistance program,
it sits within what we call our affordable Housing Fund, and the Mortgage
Assistance Program is just one program. It's like the only
program we run right now, but it's a program in there. So when that was
funded, that program was funded at $1 million, $1.1 million. It was
like $1 million and then $100,000 that was for some
administrative costs to make sure that it kept running.
So we are, we're going to run out of that. We basically
have all that million dollars that was originally assigned for that specific— and that
million was directly related to the grant awards that we were issuing.
So with what has been approved and in the process right now, we either would
have to stop and not take any more applications and just finish
the ones that we have and that have been approved, or we need to
add some funding to get you through the end of this fiscal year.
So I talked with Evan and Kiara a little bit about this in terms
of what that would look like. And so it really is just,
again, a decision of the council to say we— so
the money that we get for this, it specifically comes from the redevelopment areas.
So there's a component in there that requires a percentage of that money to come
towards affordable housing. And, um,
so this, this particular program here,
we either would need to kind of end it until we reappropriate money,
or we need to consider reappropriating. So the
request that has been submitted in here is to ask for
an additional $500,000 between now and June 30th.
That would, on average, allow us to issue about, you know, 4 grants
a month through the rest of the fiscal year. So— Can you give
us an idea? I know that it's kind of a moving target because some
of our projects are coming online and haven't
reached their full property value potential. But what are we typically bringing
in every year into the fund right now?
What was last year's? It's about $1.5 million. So last
year was a bigger influx because we had some more area that triggered from
that, but about $1.5 million right now per
year. We had a balance going into it. Yes.
So I have all of that information available if you want me to
pull it up. It's in my notes, but I can't see my notes
and I can't tell you all the numbers off the top of my head.
It's okay. But we have reserves, so it doesn't impact the reserves. It really
isn't going to impact your ability to do any of the other programs. So that
was one of the things we wanted to talk to with Kiara and Evan,
you know, like with the housing programs and the different things. I know you guys
have had some information that's come through through from the planning side, and there's
just a lot of things that we're looking at. And that was something that was
important to the council, is that we don't want to tie up all of the
affordable housing dollars into a single program. We want to have diversity
in terms of what we're able to do with these funds and available.
One other thing that we are using this money for is we do
use it to reimburse the general fund for our mandatory contribution to the homeless
shelter. So the state takes a percentage of our sales tax
dollars. It's based on a population base each month that goes there. So the
reimbursement amount right now is about $235,000
a year. And that money comes out of affordable
housing and it goes and it reimburses the general fund from those sales tax dollars
that were used for that contribution initially. So it's a qualifying event and
we— and so we use that for that purpose. Is the Olin-Walker
contribution based on population? It is based on population,
so it changes every year in January, and then we get
our number and we're set for the year. So I think it's
important for the new council members to understand that we're going to pay that one
way or the other. It'll come out of general fund money
if it has to, because it's a contribution that the state— it's a mandatory contribution
to that fund. And because we have these RDA dollars that come in through the
affordable housing, it's been able to fund that contribution. Sure.
So it's really helpful that that happened. But, but it— there,
we're generating $1.5 million, and that number is going to go up a year in
RDA affordable housing dollars, at least for the foreseeable future.
That looks like that's going to be the case. So I'll just say
from my perspective, I have no issues allocating an additional $500,000
from my perspective, Kimberly, to that, to that process through the end of fiscal
2020— is it 2025, 2026? I have no
issues with that. I don't know how everyone else feels about it. And I
think it's really important. One of the things that's made me really nervous about these
funds is that they continue to grow, and we really had no program in
place where we could expend them. And my concern was
that big brother was going to look over our shoulder and say, gosh, Eagle Mountain,
if you've got $2.5 million or $3.5 million or $5 million for
affordable housing that you're not putting to work, we've got a good place for it
to go, and it's going to be in Draper or somewhere else. I don't know.
And so I think it's really important that we're cognizant of putting these funds
to work to produce exactly what they're designed to produce.
I wholeheartedly agree with Council Member Wright. I think the thing that
I would ask though is, um, is staff starting
to look at potential other options? And will
that be something that we'll get to talk about soon as a council?
Because we've talked about revitalization grants,
we've talked about ADU grants, different things like that, and we
never wanted it to be like a voucher system per se.
We always wanted to foster homeownership and just stability
within our community. And I don't want it all to
go to MAP, but right now that's the only program we have.
So as we're looking to the future, I'm excited
for, especially with some of our new council members and their experience,
looking at other ways that we can make good use of this money.
It sounds like the demand is still pretty high for the program, right?
We're not having any trouble placing those resources in the hands of
people who qualify? That's correct. What we are seeing is we
are issuing more Tier 3 grants than we are the Tier
1 and Tier 2. And so one of the things that
we might talk about is that even though
we have a certain amount of dollar that is there, do you want it to
be broke out between those tiers where we're trying to target, or is it just
a matter— as long as the goal is that we can help people get
to Eagle Mountain? So I would love to see the data
on how that's been distributed, Kimberly. I know it would fund about 40 forgivable loans,
um, the million dollars that was set aside for those, those purposes.
I would be really interested in just seeing that data. How long is it taking
for those loans, those applications to be made? How many
are we seeing a month on average? How many are approved? How many are rejected?
How many qualify? How many don't? It'd just be good to get a sense of,
is this something that's going to continue in perpetuity, at least
to some degree? Is there going to be a waning a
waning desire to participate or need to participate? And if so, I think we'd like
to be aware of that sooner rather than later. So we are planning for
a retreat in April. We're talking about having a retreat maybe even before
that time. We're trying to find a date, and that's one of the things I
wanted to talk to the council with later tonight. But with that,
one of the topics is specifically RDA funds, how you want to
use them. and prioritize them. That came out of the previous retreat as something
that you wanted to come back to discuss.
That's it. That's it. So— So
is there any other questions about the presentation? This is a public hearing, so— You
can ask all the questions. And I want to get them out before the public
hearing. That's actually a good thing. So— Anything else?
Okay, thank you, Kimberly. With that, this is a public hearing,
and so we will take care of that now, and I
will open the public hearing at 8:31. And before I do that,
actually, Lacey, is our recording good, the streaming and everything?
Okay, sorry, I'm a little late on that. I tried.
Okay, so at 8:31 we'll open the public hearing. Is there anyone here to
speak on that? Yeah, Jesse Southworth.
Hello, excuse me, Mayor and Council. Um, I'm sure if you saw my face during
that, you know that I'm not super thrilled with
the budget. Um, I first had an issue just with the,
the digital sign at Quarry Ride Park because I think that our current
signs are, uh,
semi-worthless. Mostly they're hard
to see and they're primarily used to promote the city's social media pages.
Sometimes I see videos of fields on there, but I'd prefer to look at the
real thing. So I think that the signs are
a waste of money, but at first I was thinking that it was going to
be something where, oh, we have this extra money, let's put it on these signs,
as Zach asked. But it
seems that we have extra money, so now I'd like to know what is it
that we have to do to get some of that $5 million that
we have sitting around invested into some of the older parts of our city.
Um, City Center right here, you just go east of here, there are
plenty of trails and things that are— there's no
paved paths, things that were left unfinished. And repeatedly last
year I heard that we weren't going to do anything with this open space
because we don't have any money to do it. And now that seems that— I
don't know, either we're going to put a sign and use the money there,
or we have extra money sitting somewhere that could be done there. So now I'm
just curious as to what could be done, um,
to get that money used there. Also, I know that it's
probably $2,000 maybe a year that to maintain some
of the CMS programs and the, the software for the signs, but I
do know that those digital signs, especially one that would be the
size that I expect, the one at the park
would be, cost significantly more.
Usually it's about 10 to 15% of the
initial cost of installing it per year just
to maintain functionality of it. But I mean, I'm willing to
be wrong on that, but really at this point I would just love some of
that budget to go towards bettering the existing parts of the city and
maintaining trail connection, even if that's one of the things. So So thank you.
That is all.
Okay. I have a feeling there's more.
Charlotte Ducos. All right.
Charlotte Ducos. I actually— I love the idea
of trying to improve communication. I think that having a sign
Especially if it's multidirectional, so if you can see it from both
sides, I think is a good idea. I do think that we need to communicate
with our residents what's going on and who's invited and all of that
information. I hope that the cost comes down a little bit from what's
on there. I think that's a lot of money.
And so I'm hoping that it is a little bit lower than that. But the
thing that I actually really wanted to speak to is— Thank you.
Because of the project that I do in my classroom,
where we've looked at the budget for many years, I know that those utility sales
funds are something that have been sitting there for a really long time because they've
been there since my project started. I also know that one of
the proposed uses for those funds was the city streetscapes here
in City Center, as well as other
types of improvements in the city center.
My— what I heard tonight is that $200,000,
$300,000 of that is going to go to a sign,
possibly, which means that there's a whole lot more that's
still there for those streetscapes. I think if we're looking at trying to build
an upscale city center, we need to start working on those
streetscapes. And so my encouragement is, if you want to build
a sign, let's build it at the most cost-effective way that we can. I think
that it has value. But I think we need to
commit to doing these projects that have been sitting there for a really long time
and really contribute to the quality of life and the aesthetic
beauty of our city, particularly here in the city center.
As well as one of the things that I heard a lot as I campaigned
last year is the visibility and the landscaping and
the water waste that is on ranches.
Parkway as well, and we talked about
the expense of xeriscaping some of those areas,
taking down some of that berming and making it a little easier to see
there. And it seems like some of that money might be able to be used
for some of our hardest visibility areas,
you know, along our main corridors as well. And so I know
that some of it is not just having the funding; it's having the. people and
the manpower to do the job. I understand that that is a huge issue
there, but, but if the money can be used for
the landscaping, it can probably be used for some manpower as well if we need
to hire in some seasonal to help with that. Very second second. And so
that would be my encouragement, is as we're looking at our next year's budget,
as was mentioned, those, those dollars are depreciating, so let's get them spent.
And I would encourage it to be on of those projects that have already
been— like, we allocated it and then unallocated it. So let's reallocate that
and get some of those longstanding projects done that would benefit residents
in this area of town.
Okay, is there anyone else who would like to speak on this topic?
Sorry, I beat you to it. Okay, we'll have you go, and then,
and then just make sure you fill out the paperwork and give it to Lacey
afterwards, but state your name for the record. And you can turn in your paper.
Go ahead. Uh, Jay Johnson. I live in Glenmar Ranches.
Um, I work for Yesco. I proposed the display
that, uh, you guys are looking at. Um, one of the things that was
brought up was maintenance. Um, there is some
maintenance to, uh, to anything, um, but it's very low,
uh, a lot less than 10 or 15% on average.
Um, I could get you numbers on that if people are interested.
The other big thing is, is the city, I'm sure, has advertising dollars they're
spending elsewhere that they could probably take that from certain
areas and put into this.
So the display is quite a bit larger than the other ones, and I
do agree that it could be better managed as far as the content that's
on it, which Yesco could help with. Thank you.
as well. So, um, one big thing with the new display,
um, it does come with a 5-year warranty on everything. So there's
no maintenance from an initial standpoint for
5 years. So, um, again, just— I
live in Glenmar Ranch, is real close to this. One other thing that people will
have a question about is light pollution. Um,
this sign's designed to be directional for the light, um,
and then it follows a lot stricter rules on where the
light can broadcast and how far it does and how it dims. So I
live close enough that if this was to go up tomorrow, I would see it
from my back porch. So if I didn't want it there, that,
that would be a thing. Or there's already lighting issues with this particular
area. So anyways, thank you.
Jeff Ruth. Jeff Ruth
from the Landing neighborhood. I just want to say I like the idea
of the sign. I think bringing out that road sign, parking it over there,
it gives very little information. It's tacky.
I think the sign is very much needed, especially for all the events at Corey
Ride. So like I say, I think it's a good idea
and money well spent. Thank you.
All right, is that everybody? Seeing no one,
seeing no one, we will close the public hearing portion at 8:39
and bring it back to the council. I think it'd be useful
just to have a quick refresher course on what
the utility sale funds were like designated as and what is
already committed, because I feel I feel like within the last 8
years, we've talked about a very specific dollar amount for medians
in city center and park strips, streetscapes,
all of those things. And we've also,
when the original council and mayor, which I was not on,
made kind of the determination of buckets of
money, they wanted to make sure that the money was evenly
spread spent between the ranches and city center so that it
wouldn't be all of the stuff up at the ranches. And there were
some improvements made to the medians there when
Mayor Pengra was our mayor to help reduce the
plants that had water needs and different things like that. So it's
kind of almost like a phased approach, but maybe someone from staff,
either someone who's been here a long time or maybe Brad, can talk about— Yeah.
Where we're headed with the funds for streetscapes. Is it
still allocated or have we peeled that back?
And just kind of give us an update to that because I think it's a
very valuable and important question that was asked.
So we do that every year in our budget when we go through the budget
meetings, which one of them will be later today. And each time we look
at those funds, she shows us— and last year when she showed us, we reallocated
those Because like currently the medians are coming out.
As opposed to improving those, we're actually gonna pull those out and expand
lanes. So, but we look at those every single year in our budget process,
that entire account. Agreed. I just think that some
of the reasons that have been given about why we weren't gonna pull them out
was one, we didn't know if medians were gonna stay. Two, there were utilities
that were coming and going in the spaces. On the park
strips. And instead of having to pay to landscape it twice,
those were some of the things. So maybe Brad can just give some context for
us. Yeah, I think you're spot on. I mean, I think that that's what
we brought up back in Pangra's time. We had moved
forward and we were going to do a bunch of landscaping. And then
we had a whole bunch of utility companies coming through with fiber lines
and all sorts of things down the side sides of roads.
And we've watched that happen in the ranches where it's all developed and whatnot.
And as a staff member, I didn't feel like it
was adequate at the time to go in and install all this brand new landscaping
just to have trenches and everything cut into it. Now I
get that there is a timing for everything and that you should improve
some of these things and whatnot, but that time just didn't feel like it
was the time. We had heavy growth, tons of fiber lines,
tons of utilities down the sides of the road.
And so we've kind of held back on that.
I'm speaking off— I haven't looked at the utility
self-funds, so you can't hold me to the exact number, but I'm pretty sure there
was around $500,000 for medians, and I think there was about $750,000
for the landscapes on the sides of the road that was allocated.
and then initial utility sale funds from those sale
proceeds. That being said, I don't think that those have ever been
grouped back into the— they got sucked back in. We've always
kept them line itemed out. And so if it is something
that we wanna move forward, that's something that we can discuss in the budget process.
And if we wanna see it done, then we prioritize it and we figure out
a plan to get it done. That's my recommendation. Thank you. I— oh,
sorry. Is that right? I'm a chatty Cathy tonight. I just
think that maybe being cognizant of the whole utilities
thing and having to deal with the trench digging and replacing
and all of those things, we are a city that
can figure things out and come up with creative solutions.
And maybe we look at ways that we can improve the look and feel and
continuity of the city city center streetscapes
without making it subject to as much change
because of utilities. So, and I agree, I think that
that line, those 2 line items were kept separate. At least that's the
way that I remember it. So it's always been like a little bucket of money
that eventually we were going to deal with it. So anyway.
Brad, you and I over the years went back and forth on Sage Valley,
and I would just Just imagine there's probably 20 people like that that you
have calling you saying, hey, can we get a trail? Can we do this?
Those little connections, they— last year, for example, we finished
a path around Sage Valley, and that was such
a huge win, you have no idea. That just that project, I don't know how
it was paid for. Maybe it came out of this. But do you have a
list of projects like that that are big
wins for the residents? Yeah. But maybe not a relatively huge cost
for the city or to pull from this fund?
So I— no, I don't have a big list. And, and part of it
is, is like, uh, over here in the city center, there is a lot of
open space acres. And I mean, we've had a lot of discussions about that.
And so it's— there, by volume, there's so much. And so where do
you start? Where do you stop? Um, what are we
going to do with it long term? Are we going to keep some of it?
Are we not going to keep some of it. Like, we've had discussions about every
scenario, and so I think collectively we just
need to continue to have those conversations to understand the direction
that we want to go. Because the same way that I just talked about the
roadscapes, I don't think it makes sense to go in and landscape something and then
turn around and get rid of it. So until we have a
plan and a path forward, I think it's wise to just have discussions
and figure out what that approach looks like. To answer your question about majority
of the asks that we get are, hey, can we have a couple more benches?
Can we have a couple more trash cans? Like, that's stuff that we facilitate all
the time and we don't say no and we take care of those things
out of the operating budget. Sometimes with these trail
networks and whatnot, those have been advantageous
for us to do them because we have a paving machine. And so we're
able to install some of those trails at a low cost.
Um, but I do know putting in landscaping,
um, it comes— irrigation systems come with a significant cost,
uh, watering turf comes with a cost, and all those things. And just with
the climate of everything, we just got to be wise in the decisions that we
make. Thank you. So just as a council,
maybe, and mayor, just— we'll just keep track as we're residents reach out
to those various projects and add them into this next budget year.
I think what I heard is he said you're the only squeaky wheel. That's,
I think, what I just heard. That's kind of
what I took. But he responded. He got it done. It's awesome.
Yeah, we'll keep track of those.
Obviously, there's a lot of trails here that I think we could connect and probably
pretty inexpensive. That's one that we could definitely Put on.
Sorry, one other thing that I think is really important. When the
utility sale funds originally happened, there was a grant program
that was created, and it was much like what I envisioned
the RAP tax board and the grants for that.
So one thing that I'm really excited about is now we're going to have this
very specific pot of money that can be used for projects
like this, and we're going to create a mechanism by which our residents can can
submit a request and help demonstrate
a need, and then this body of people are gonna be able to just help
us decide as a council what we spend that money on.
So like, there's a bright future ahead is what I'm trying to say.
And I'll just say this on that point. I know I've had some conversations
with council members. I agree with Council Member Wright that that
money's not— it's depreciating in value.
To be quite frank, but at the same token, are there other
needs that we could better use it for? Because this
would qualify for a bucket of money that is restricted, and these are unrestricted.
So you know, specifically the
sign—that's something the rap tax could pay for, and these unrestricted
funds could be used on you know something. I don't
have any ideas. I'm just just considering the fund.
Can I ask a question? So with all the open space acres in downtown or
in city center, where is that? Is that on someone's desk somewhere
about planning and designing, or is that just not any— no one's working on it
currently? Well, I can tell you that I've done an
extensive amount of work, and in fact, you and I walked some of the trails
over there. We walked it, but is there a plan in place? Or is someone
going to create a plan? What I can tell you, what we've been working
on, I've worked with both Brad and Zach mostly, and about
what is the future there. And it's really,
I know the residents thought about bike parks
and different things, but we haven't got any traction on that. So I think it
just needs more of a conversation. So I think this is— It's
brought up because of the land disposal, right? Yeah. Council Member Whiting, I mean,
the truth of the matter is, is that we do have a Parks, Trails,
and Open Space Plan, and it's in the process of being updated. It's not perfect,
but but our staff's worked really hard to kind of review those areas
that exist in the city and make recommendations.
And I think you're in the middle of doing that now, aren't you? So we'll
be looking at something fairly soon that will be an update to our existing plan.
So it does exist, but it's hard to implement
it without some of those resources. And so then it's a matter of the council
has to really prioritize and say we're ready to tackle this one.
Are are we going to? tackle youth sports. I mean,
it's, it's always these competing interests where you have to look at it and say,
where are we going to put the limited resources that we have? Because they are
limited, and, and many of them are restricted. So it's,
it's a balancing act in trying to decide. Sometimes we have— I
had a resident get really frustrated with me one day because we approved the Smith
Ranch Park at $8 million. That's a lot of money.
One of the first things I did as a council member, and I had to
help him understand that that was a restricted bucket of money that
could only be used for those things. It was park impact fees.
So I think sometimes we don't understand all of that even as council
members, and certainly our residents don't, that those funds can only go to
certain places. And so when they're unrestricted like the utility cell,
they're pretty precious because they're rare, number one.
So to answer your question, I know staff's working on that.
So do we need to host like an open house? Like when our consultants
come for projects we're working on, they host these open houses, get a lot
of different ideas. Do we need to host an open house in the city center
saying, hey, give us ideas for this land?
Because it seems to me, you know, we've got a few million
dollars sitting aside. And Councilmember Clark, you said prior
councils have said let's make this an equal distribution between ranches and city center,
and I'm saying we should shift most of that to city center. I think
that's where most of the needs would be. And this seems to be one of
those needs where we've got these vacant parcels that we can make— that we can
beautify as long as— we just got to get a plan in place and
then see what it costs. And then some of these are going to be low
cost. Trail systems could be super low cost, and we got to and decide what
we want to do with it. I, just to clarify, the splitting
up of the funds has already taken place. The amount that's going to be spent
in the ranches has been spent. The remainder of it really is
mostly city center money. So you're right.
I also, you had said something about, are we gathering
feedback? When we redid our parks,
trails, and open space plan, there are multiple, like,
Open house, little farmer's market, you know,
like those kinds of things. And that's one of the reasons why
I think us going on our listening tour is really important. We're going to be
in City Center this Thursday, and we can hear from the residents that
are excited for something to be done,
what they want done. That's a great opportunity for us to hear that, so.
Thank you.
Can we come back to item 9? Yeah.
All right, we're back to the budget amendment,
which obviously there's a lot of things in here that we've got kinda
in the weeds on. So let's come back to any specific questions
on the amendment items.
So far nothing. If not, I will accept a motion.
I'll give it a whirl. Mayor, I move that we approve—
let me get the right, uh,
resolution— of Eagle Mountain City approving the 2nd Amendment to the fiscal year 2025-2026
annual budget, uh, with the
proposed amendment resulting in an overall budget increase of $8,014,123,
bringing the total FY25-26 budget to
$163,179,862
and 5.16% increase over the previous adjusted
budget. I'll second.
Okay, we have a motion by Council Member Wright and a second by Council Member
Huish. And yeah,
that's as presented is what I see, right? Yeah. So the motion is as
presented. Any discussion
on the motion? Clear? All right, we'll start the vote with Council
Member Whiting. Yes. Council Member Huish? Yes. Council Member Clark?
Yes. Council Member Wright? Yes. That motion passes.
All right, moving along. The next item, 16A, is resolution
of Eagle Mountain City authorizing the issuance
Issuance of— get my tongue to work— and sale of not more than
$220 million aggregate principal amount of water and sewer revenue bonds.
I believe this one's actually— is Laura online?
And wasn't there an update to it too that we got an email? Does he
need to say it differently or are we good? Is the motion
just needs to be made differently?
Okay, and this one is, uh, Ben, do you want to lead us into this
or have Laura help us or Kimberly? I see
her, but she can't— I can't hear her. Oh, you're here for— Gilmore Bell.
So if you want to speak here on behalf of— Sure.
Um, I, I can paraphrase my— the memo that I put out
that was posted online. I appreciate that, Council Member Clark. And I do believe
Laura is We had some connection
issues, so if we need to, we'll probably have to call and then
do a speakerphone. Okay, very good.
Thank you. So ultimately, this is a project
that is much needed within our community to meet
contractual obligations for the continued growth in our community and
the entitlements that many of our, our developers have with within
our community. This is
a 200— basically, this is what's called a bond parameters resolution,
and it is not necessarily setting the amount of
any kind of bond at this point. It is really putting the outside parameters
or the guardrails on a future bond that
the city would consider. But this is the first step. The bond super
parameter resolution is actually what it's It's called. And it's the first step that basically
outlines the City Council's intent to move forward with projects
both in our water and our sewer fund and outlines the,
like I said, those guardrails around those projects. So the 3 projects that this
project really, this potential bonding would cover,
would be a new 6 million gallons per day sewer
treatment plant expansion. That's right. And a sewer trunk
line project and a Central Utah Water pipeline and booster pump project.
In the actual language of the, uh, of the
bond parameters resolution, it's really outlining that this is
for water and wastewater enhancements,
but those are the, the intended 3 projects that we would use the funds for.
The bond parameters resolution also establishes the anticipated
anticipated maximum bond amount, the maximum possible interest rate,
maximum duration, par amounts, and whatnot. So basically it's
the parameters by which we would operate. At this early
stage in the process, we are still working to refine the costs on our
sewer treatment project. It's also— we're also in the design phase,
and in fact the council just a few minutes ago approved funding
for the design of the East Trunk Line, and so we appreciate that.
So all of those costs are under refinement, but we have high-level engineers'
estimates that we have included in this, along with contingency
to ensure that the bond parameters resolution is going to be large enough to
ensure that we can move forward with these projects. But we
anticipate the actual cost to come in much lower. The reason we
want to start early in the process of having a bond parameters
resolution is not only one, to engage the public and allow them to
come to a public hearing and participate in that process,
but also two, we want to ensure that we have the
best possible cost and the least likelihood
of project schedule delays by being able to order long
lead time items early, such as transformers
or the membranes in the membrane bioreactor, those things that
would take upwards of a year to 2 years to acquire, we want to make
sure that we get those ordered at the lowest possible price, which is today's price,
and we get those coming and they're on hand so that when the project
does move forward, we can, one, make sure that we have them and
it's not going to cause any scheduling delays, and two,
that that we
can reimburse ourselves for those purchases out of future bond
proceeds. Part of this bond parameters resolution anticipates
that we would use bond proceeds to be able to pay for those hard costs.
Without such a resolution in place, we would only be
able to reimburse ourselves for design costs. So that's the general high-level
view of what a bond parameters resolution is.
Involves. We will continue to work on refining
the costs involved. Like I said, we will continue to work on
looking for grants and low-interest or zero-interest loans that
we can put towards this. Of course, we have to go through a process
to become bond-rated to be able to ensure that we are— our
credit rating is good. And then we will look at market conditions and
when it's the best time to move forward based on the solidification of all of
that information. Um, uh,
but with the passage of this bond resolution, we start the public process,
and the council is envisioning that we will— that you'll be
setting a public hearing, um, for the purpose of gathering public
input on March 5th at 5:30 PM. Um, with that,
I'm going to turn the time over to our good friends at Gilmore Bell To
be able to answer any other questions or to correct anything I lied about just
a few minutes ago. And Laura is online too. And Laura as well. So you
guys can battle over who says what. We might be having
microphone issues with Laura's mic, so she might have to call in.
Oh, got it. That's perfect.
Can you— See if she can—
Right there, okay. Okay, Laura, I'll,
uh, when you get mic more, that you can chime in and correct me where
I'm wrong as well. So I'm Garrett Gross, Gilmore Bell. We're bond counsel to the
city. Um, any, any— first off, couple great,
um, uh, great summary there and description,
very thorough, of, of the bonding process and what the parameters resolution
is intended to accomplish. I will note, uh, we did
Also make a couple little tweaks to the resolution. We upped it
to $230 million because there's potentially, just to provide the
city some optionality to possibly refinance
some outstanding bonds. So we just threw that, we raised it at Laura's
and Louis Young's suggestion, $10 million. We've adopted that,
or we've drafted that, and that should be in the actual resolution.
Are we saying that that would be to refinance existing bonds that
we have? That was the difference in the $10
million. That additional $10 million would be to refinance outstanding water
revenue and sewer revenue bonds of the city. And a net savings
to the city if we were to do that, potentially based on the interest rates
we obtain. Right, exactly. So we're doing that now to preserve
that flexibility, and it was done last minute.
There's actually 2 separate notices that were created because
state law requires that those notices of the public hearing
that'll be— that'll take place on March 5th,
that 14 days of notice are given. So we actually added
that to the parameters resolution, you know, late in the game, as you'll see
there. So with that said, great summary. Any questions?
Any on the parameters resolution, the process?
So I think we wanted to ensure that there's a call provision that's
included in this, and is that in there?
So the tip— great question. The typical— most,
you know, when you go with a smaller issuance, when you go typically
to a private institution or a single lender, there's a little bit more flexibility
in those call provisions. For a potentially larger
issue, And in order to get the best rates,
typically on what we call a market deal where the bonds
are sold to the public securities markets, there's typically
a call restriction of about 10 years. And that's flexible
in terms of— but typically you have to pay more in
terms of an interest rate for that flexibility. But 9 to 10 years is typically
the standard on that for those— Non-call. Are those
options you provide us at the time then when this becomes available and you say,
okay, here's without a call provision, here's with a call provision,
and here's the parameters of that, and then the city's able to decide what
we feel like might be the best? Correct, yep, yep. Luis Young and Laura Lust,
they would work with you. We advise on the legal
side, but they would work with you on the financial side on what to
help you get the best financial terms. And working with
potential underwriters on what would be the most advantageous provisions
for the city at the time based on the market conditions.
And I should— I probably failed to note when we started this discussion,
but Mr. Huish is quiet because you have, uh,
you wanted to recuse yourself on this one. So yeah, I just for work
purposes need to recuse myself from any discussion or vote on the bond specifically.
Okay. So is there any other questions?
Does this microphone work for Laura yet?
Can you hear us, Laura?
She can hear us, but we can't hear her.
If you want to put it by the microphone, then we Sure.
We're going to mic you in, Laura. So I think
the one thing that we have to— and I don't know how that works— is
we'll get a loopback because we'll be able to hear what
she's hearing when it comes through the speaker. So we'll
see. She needs to mute and then— And
then just try to listen through the phone.
I cannot mute the screen that I'm
on. The buttons don't work. Can you make it though so that
you can't— you're not listening to us through— yeah,
so turn the volume down so you don't listen to us through the Lifesize
link, just through the phone.
How's that? Okay. So we'll see if you can— we can hear you.
Can you hear us? Yes, I can. How is that on your end?
Good. Perfect. Excellent.
All right, well, first of all, I apologize for whatever's going on that
you can't hear me and we had to improvise, but you know, things,
things happen. I do appreciate you let me present from home.
I was diagnosed with pneumonia on Friday, and I'm— notwithstanding
a whole bunch of antibiotics, I'm still a little bit on the recovery So
I do appreciate the option of not having to drive down there
and have you listen to me hack my head off when I start coughing.
Just a few other things to add what Garrett has indicated
to you. I'm going to touch first on the call provision. That question was
just asked. Garrett covered that very well. There are
occasions in the market when we can get an 8-year call
without paying higher interest costs.
We are always able to get a 10-year par call,
and sometimes I'm going to say, you know,
30% of the time we can get a 9-year call without an additional
premium. So we would discuss with the city, is it worth paying,
you know, whatever the extra might be, 5 basis points, 10 basis points,
to have it callable any earlier? You know, I'd certainly want
to know before we agree to that, what you think the source of revenues might
be to have revenues to pay earlier.
You know, could be impact fees. Impact fees are eligible
to pay these bonds. So there, you know, we will have
a lot of discussion in that regard. And a couple of other things I just
wanted to mention in Section 1, where it talks about the
maximum parameters, then introduced to you.
We've kept the par amount of $230
million, as he indicated, to account for that refunding.
You don't have to issue that many bonds if the refunding does not make
economic sense at the time we go to price. We will not do
the refunding and it will stay outstanding at its current rates.
So that par amount could be less. We have a maximum
interest rate of 6.5%, but it might be helpful to know that right now today,
if we were in the market, I would expect that interest rate to be closer
to 4.5% or 4.6% with 5% coupons
on those bonds. And we've also got 35 years maximum
maturity. But again, we're currently running numbers assuming a 30-year maturity.
I always advocate for a little bit of flexibility. I'm not expecting interest
rates to go up But the last thing I want to do is try to
predict where interest rates are going. So if they were to go up and
made the debt service problematic, we could
amortize it over 31 years or 32 years and end
up with the debt service that we have. I think I
had one other thing relative
to the designated officers that need to approve
the final pricing. I will need those individuals on the
final pricing call. I don't know when that will be today. As we
get through the calendar and we know when
and how much money you need, we will have a pricing date. And I
will be very cognizant of making sure that the city
manager and your finance director are aware of that date and they clear it
for the mayor or mayor pro tem. It's typically a morning
call around 11 o'clock. to do that pricing, and, and we would
get you, you know, prepped for that call. It's generally a pretty quick call,
so it's not like you have to keep your whole, you know, day open for
it. And I think everything
else has been discussed that I would want to mention,
again, unless you have any, um, additional questions.
Laura, can you just speak to— and, or maybe you or Or
the gentleman here, can you just speak to the revenue sources that would be utilized
to repay this bond?
So yeah, so, so for these bonds, they would
be limited, limited to water and sewer revenues, right? There wouldn't be general
taxes, no, no taxes. The way we structured this is
such that it would be limited to those fees that
would be pledged right now. That doesn't restrict necessarily
from allocating or, you know,
paying out of other funds, but typically has to be restricted to what
can be pledged is those fees from water and sewer revenues.
It's the impact fees specifically? Is it user fees? Is it
rent fees? Yeah, typically. All of the above? It would be user fees that would
be the pledge or the collateral, if you will. And impact fees
can be used but can't be used as collateral. As collateral. They can't be pledged,
right? Yep, correct.
I mean, I, I, and I don't know if this is a question as much
as a comment, and I, because I think it might be helpful to have some
additional, some city council members on that call. And it may be,
I think it would be difficult probably to have depending on when that call has
to happen and how much notice you need. Like, how much notice, I guess,
is needed before that call? It's like, is it one of those things where there's
a week notice, a 2-week notice, like a day notice?
I can respond to that. Yeah, let's see. Go ahead, Laura.
I think I heard the question of how much notice is needed before,
um, uh, we set that pricing call. We usually
know a week in advance, uh, when that pricing call
is. I can tell you it will 99% chance be on
a Tuesday, Wednesday, or Thursday morning. We typically try to avoid
pricings on Monday or Friday. And so we would know a
week in advance of the day. We would not
know probably until the day before what the time would be.
And we'd like to allow for a little bit of flexibility if it's a
tough day in the market. You know, we might— underwriters—
I don't underwrite the bonds. Underwriters may need an extra hour
or 2 to market the bonds. But again, we just want a
little bit of flexibility on that day of the final pricing.
Might, might I recommend that you keep it the way it is with the
mayor and the manager acting on behalf of, but call a special meeting as
soon as this is made known so that the council can be fully brought up
to speed and can give direction to the mayor and manager to be able
to move forward administratively towards that end? So there's some
certain requirements I think that might help too, Kimberly, that you've talked about.
It has to be an elected— one elected official.
I can't remember the— there's— yeah,
I mean, that has to— that can accept the prices. So we've set
up the resolution such that the council would authorize
the mayor, mayor pro tem, the city manager, as well as
I believe the finance director. I'd have to double-check on that. I think
we have just the mayor and manager right now. I think that's okay. Yeah,
we might have modified that last minute. So yeah,
no, that's— but that's
the minimum. But yes, you are more than welcome to obviously
have— That's what I was getting at is the minimum, it has to be that,
but the others can be on a call or something.
Correct. So can you address how would this—
so the bond passes, how would that affect? Taxes in
the city? Are taxes going to go up for citizens to help pay for the
bond? So direct— I mean, no, directly no.
This bond is what we call a water sewer revenue bond,
where the collateral, as we mentioned earlier, is solely restricted
to the water and sewer fees, right? The fees from
that system. No taxes
can— legally, they can't be pledged. To the
repayment of the bonds. So would those sewer and water fees potentially go up then?
I mean, they could, right? I mean, there's certain covenants
that are in the bond or that are in the, what we call the
indenture, which is the legal governing provisions for
the bonds. And to the extent there was,
per se, not sufficient what we call debt service coverage,
You know, potentially the city might have to raise rates
in order to meet those coverage ratios. Now, from what I understand,
and I'll let Laura speak on this, the financial position of the city is such
that I don't anticipate that that would have to happen in the future,
but I don't want to speak for the— So yeah, Laura's raising her hand,
so I'd like to make sure that she has the time because I
do believe they will. They will. Okay. I misspoke.
Go ahead, Laura. Thank you. As Gary indicated,
uh, with the security for these bonds, there would be no obligation
for the city to raise taxes. That is crystal clear under state law.
If you had such an obligation, that would have to be voted upon by your
citizens. So what we pledge here are those system
revenues, which are inclusive of water, Sewer and storm
sewer. This is a very large project,
and I anticipate that the city will need to continue.
It's done a very good job in the past, in recent
past, of increasing your water and sewer
rates occasionally. We are looking
to structure the debt so that it will increase over
time, unlike, you know, when you all go get a residential
mortgage. Okay. I get a residential mortgage. If I want a fixed rate,
I get a fixed payment that's the same every month. They don't care if I'm
going to be earning more or less in the future. I just get the same
payment. In the municipal bond world, we have the ability
to structure the debt around estimated
increases in revenue. So when we think of Eagle Mountain,
it's like, oh, there's going to be a lot of population. growth. So we are
working with a debt service coverage model
where we'll take into account what your historical population growth has
been. We'll probably dial that down again to show the markets that
we're being, you know, conservative. But in addition to that,
I believe there will need to be rate increases of—
I mean, I'm ballparking it now, so please don't, you know,
freak out or whatever, because we still have a lot of number crunching
to do, but I'm expecting, you know, somewhere between,
you know, 3% and maybe 5% on,
you know, a multi-annual basis.
Again, it depends on, on the population.
So when we issue the bonds, as Gary indicated, you will
covenant that you will maintain rates and charges such
that your net revenues So all your gross revenues less
your operating expenses will generate $1.25
for every dollar in debt payment. We'll be very mindful
of that as we're issuing the bonds and we show them a projected
debt service coverage table. So that is what
we're expecting at the moment. Again, we'll refine that as we move forward.
Well said, Laura. Yeah, legally there's not a requirement other
than to We're going to meet the ratios, but she's right, you know, practically speaking,
it sounds like there may have to be some raising
of the rates over time.
Okay. I don't see any other questions.
If there's nothing else to speak on, I'll entertain a motion.
Nobody wants to make that motion. Okay,
Council Member Whitey. Okay, Mayor, I motion—
I move to approve a resolution of Eagle Mountain
City, Utah, authorizing the issuance and sale of not more than—
we're saying $230 million aggregate
principal amount of water and sewer revenue bonds Series 2026.
As presented here in the agenda.
Second. Okay, we have a motion by Councilmember
Whiting and a second by Councilmember Wright. Is there any questions or discussion on the
motion? Can I just make a statement, a public statement? Sure.
I think it's just important for our residents to understand. I mean, $230 million makes
me sick to my stomach. I'm just gonna say that.
Kind of feels like when I bought my first mortgage. I left
there excited and happy, and I'm not even excited and happy about this.
But this is an absolute necessity for our city, and I hope that
our citizens will recognize and understand that
the necessity of this has been coming our way for a number of years,
and we have not paid the attention to it that perhaps we should
have. When we received some of our earlier information
that our loading is at 100% in our current plant, the 2.4 million gallon plant.
The loading is the capacity of the plant to produce or to process
the sludge. I'm gonna call it sludge. I don't know what they call it,
chocolate milk, I'm not sure. But to process that,
the heavy solids in the sewer treatment plant,
we really thought we had still another 3 or 4 year window that we could
work towards this outcome. When that came to us
earlier this year, and we've been working on this for a couple of years.
This isn't brand new. But we're really at a point of no return
where if we do nothing, you're going to
all recognize it. And I would rather deal with you being frustrated
by a bond issuance than by the alternative that that
might create in your individual home. And there's
been promises made by this body and others to the development
community and to those who are building in our city currently that
we'll be able to process that waste and
that we'll be able to get water to their homes so that they can have
drinking tap water just like you do. And without
this, we're not going to be able to meet those obligations,
and that's not a place that you want us to put you either. So that's
a really simple explanation. I'll be happy to go into detail with anybody that wants
to hear it. Give me a call, send me an email, let's talk about
it. But the reality of it is, is This is the responsible thing for us
to do regarding our fiduciary duty. And I'll be quiet and let the mayor call
for the vote now. Craig also wants to make a comment. Yeah, and this might
be a question better answered by Ben or someone else,
but another— I think questions
that citizens might have regarding this is, wouldn't impact
fees typically be enough to not get us in a $200 million hole? And why—
so why are we here? I think it would be helpful to answer that question
as well. Sure. So first of all, the reason you can't pledge
impact fees is because they come in inconsistently. So you don't—
there's no guarantee that there's going to be 1,000 new homes every single year to
be able to pay those. There might be a year where you have 2,000.
There might be a year where we have 2008-09
where the housing market drops off. And so we have
to use collateral from a revenue standpoint from the actual user
rates. So that's probably one answer. But the second,
I think, more philosophical answer to this question is that we
are building a facility that is a 50-year or longer
facility. And the benefit to those
not only comes to the existing residents that live here today,
but the benefit will come to those residents that move
in and live here and raise their families or their kids or grandkids into the
future as our population continues to grow. And so proportionately speaking,
it makes more sense for us to ensure that impact fees and
user rates over time are paid for, for an asset that's
used over time as well, so that those who are reaping the
benefit of this asset are helping to contribute and pay for it,
and it's not all on the backs of existing residents. And historic
impact fees, to explain, it's not like the
city could have charged more historic impact fees to help us not be
in this situation, is that correct? That is correct. So historic impact fees,
of course, have been used to pay for only what's in our capital facility plan,
more specifically in our impact fee facility plan
and our impact fee analysis, which is
only over a 6-year project or period. So only those projects,
what you do over a 6-year, that 6-year window, and that's pursuant
to state code. And so we, we could only do projects that we
already had in there— trunk lines, lift stations, things like
that. And while we anticipated doing upgrades to the plant,
we, and we have collected money for that, those upgrades have
been done. At this stage, we need to be able to make
significant increases to our overall plant capacity.
And the way you can ensure that future impact fees can be used
on that is by incorporating the debt service into the IFA so that that
debt service over the next 30 years is— or 35 years or whatever it
ends up being— is being paid towards that debt as those new
residents are moving in. So new growth should be paying for new— That
makes sense. And just to hopefully Hopefully that the citizens heard portion of
what you said is state law dictates how much a
city can collect in impact fees. The city's been following the state law in terms
of what impact fees have been collected, so it's not like the city wasn't following
that and suddenly because we weren't following that now we have this bond that
has to be issued. We followed what the state has allowed us to do,
and we are now at this juncture where we're faced with what
is now. You know, there's something else that maybe,
having been through this before in a neighboring city and
having seen the pain and struggles and everything,
there's one element of this entire project that's really not ever talked
about. And that's the fact that we're using what's called membrane biotechnology,
bioreactor technology, an MBR. This is going to create a high-quality
wastewater. Yeah. Quality Type 1 sewer effluent that can be
used and reused. Now, we're working with the state of Utah right
now, amongst other cities, trying to be able to reuse that water resource within our
community, and it will be a perpetual, ever-growing resource, which is fantastic
for our, you know, the 2nd most arid state in the nation.
So that is a fantastic thing. But what is the actual economic
value if we were to try to go out and buy 6 million
gallons per day of water off the open market. That is what we're producing.
So there's an element of what we can do with that
should the state approve the reuse application that we have in right now. So there
is an asset to this as well.
Melissa, I let everybody else speak, so before we do
a vote, happy to— Sure, I'm happy to. I think the reality of it is
Government exists for the very basics— fire,
police, water, sewer, roads— and
we've tackled a bunch of those things tonight.
But the reality of it is, is this is a test we can't afford to
not get right. I've had neighbors who've had sewage
backup in their house because of some local issue in their neighborhood.
And it sucks really bad, and I can't imagine how awful
we would be as public servants if we let that happen. And the
reality of it is, is this is just like big boy and big girl stuff.
This is what we got to do, and we're—we were elected to make these tough
decisions. And I think the important part is this
is a very open and public process so that our residents
can be a part of it. We want you guys to come and tell.
Tell us what you think and weigh in on it and help
us get to the right solution together. So I echo everything
that's been asked and said, but that's my 2 cents on it.
Yeah, and I'll just say this, Councilmember Wright. In your first couple months of service,
we approved a big bond that made your stomach hurt.
And now, now we're doing another one in your first few months of your second
term. You're not running for a third term, are you? No chance of that.
It's going to get even bigger. I'm just teasing.
All right, we'll go ahead. Motion's still on the table,
and Councilmember Huish is going to be recused.
Councilmember Clark? Yes. Councilmember Wright?
Yes. Councilmember Whiting? Yes.
Okay, that passes. I'm glad we got through that one.
The next one, ordinance this is a public hearing.
Thank you, Laura. Yes, and I think it was Greg,
right? Garrett. Thank you, Garrett.
So the next— an ordinance of Eagle Mountain City, Utah, amending the Municipal Code
1595 and adopting the,
the Eagle Mountain City Wildland Urban Interface Area Map, known to—
known at the state as WUI. And we talk a lot about
I've got a 30-minute presentation for you, but I don't want to give that to
you. Condense it.
I'm just kidding. I know I'm not going to give you that.
So the Wildland Urban Interface,
WUI, is an area that—
well, first of all, there is a WUI code. Wildland Urban Interface Code.
The state has the State Construction
Code. It's in 15A, Title 15A of the
state code. And that State Construction Code adopted
the 2006 Wildland Urban
Interface Code. And then to kind of connect the dots a little bit here,
in Chapter 1595 of our code, we've adopted the
state construction code pretty much in its entirety. That includes
the WUI code. So what's interesting, if you look in our code,
we've adopted it, but we don't say where it's applicable.
On top of that, we are part of what's called the
Cooperative Wildfire System. And the
wildfire system is basically,
it's run by the Division of Forestry, Fire, and State
Lands. It's, the simple principle
basically is, okay, state will pay for our wildland
fire, fighting wildland fires, as long
as we work to prevent
and mitigate some of the fire hazards in our jurisdiction.
So, House Bill 48
of 2025 require— uh,
requires cities that are connected to
that CWS, the Cooperative Wildfire System, to enforce
the WUI code. So we, we have it,
we've adopted it, but we don't really enforce it because we don't have a map
saying where it's applicable. So that's, that's what we're proposing,
uh, That's what we've got for you tonight is a proposed map to show
where the WUI code would be applicable. And so to
give you a couple of examples of WUI requirements
here on—
so a permit is required for these types of uses like
fireworks, fireworks stand, automobile wrecking yard,
lumberyard, Things that are potentially flammable,
you gotta get a permit through
the code official, who'd be someone like the building official
or maybe even our fire marshal. Dan DeVogue
kind of plays that role for us. The other thing that
you'll notice is there's requirements for roofing
covers, eaves, downspouts.
Exterior walls, you have to have higher-grade ignition-resistant
materials in those areas.
Other thing that's kind of probably something a number of you have heard,
that a number of the council and public
here may have heard of, is defensible spaces. So if you're
building in the WUI, and if
say you're in an extreme hazard area, You'd have to have
kind of clear the brush 100 feet around a structure.
So it's just kind of a sampling. The code's,
I believe, 38 pages long. So there's a number of
But the point is just to help structures
and the built environment be safe when it's in a more,
you know, in an area that's more prone to wildfires.
So we've prepared a WUI map.
Um, it obviously— the— we, we've— we
were showing the entirety of the city, and,
uh, the— it's just the orange parts that would be in the WUI.
Um, we get to control— the city gets
to control what's included in, or what land we
include in the, uh, what lands applicable
to the WUI. Um, what we did
to come up with what areas,
uh, what areas we proposed that the council include
in that area, what we did was we used the Smooth
Structure Exposure Score, and that basically is,
it represents It considers both wildfire
likelihood and consequences of wildfire to homes.
So we used, I'm gonna get
out of this for a second and show you, and hopefully it hasn't logged me
out 'cause it logs me out every couple minutes here.
But I'm gonna show you that map in just a second. But this is Forestry
Fire and State Lands website. Yeah. They're kind of wildfire
risk. I don't know where my— maybe.
There's— so that map that you're supposed to be seeing,
what it is, is it puts That smooth structure score—it goes
from one to eight, one being the
lowest exposure and eight being the
highest. And so what we did was we went
and took the forestry fire in state lands.
You can still hear me from the microphone, I assume.
We took seven and eights. That's That's
high-risk area and then extreme-risk area.
And we mapped that on the— put that
on the city map. And voilà. Thank you so much. This guy doesn't
make enough, I don't think.
So you can— so
if you come on this map, you can see, okay, There's your yellows.
A lot of the cities— Brandon? Yeah? I'm sorry, will you adjust your mic a
little bit closer? Oh yeah, yeah. Thank you. Yep. So you can see a lot
of the more western areas in that 4. But as you come over here to
like the bench areas, you're getting into like 6s and 7s
and 8s. And so we
took the 7s and 8s and put them on that map.
Let me get back in here.
So 7s and 8s,
that's your highest, where you
have the most extreme fire hazards in the city. One thing I
did want to note is there is, some of
you have heard about a high-risk WUI.
Designation that's different than what we're
talking about here. There's— there is a— the Forestry,
Fire, and State Lands manages the high-risk
WUI area, and that's used by
the county to assess like a special fee. I think it's like $120 a year.
These areas have to pay an additional
assessment because they live in such a hazardous fire area.
And then the insurance companies, that's— they use that
mapped area. They can only use that mapped data.
It's like a floodplain map. Yeah, exactly. They have
to use that map data. They can only use
that map data in determining which area has a high
risk. They can only use that
data to determine which properties are in the high-risk WUI.
So that's— so I just wanted to get that out to
make sure that there's 2 different things here. We get to determine what we
put on this map. We can't determine what's on this
map. So again,
just trying— that was
one of the things I thought when I got here. I'm like, where's our WUI?
map. And, and so I get to help, I guess,
bring that to you and hopefully get something adopted.
Um, one thing I will note again with 7s and 8s,
I took all of the— if you,
um, don't get to zoom in on this super well, but I,
after talking with— as I gone through this, I worked with,
uh, Chief Fossum, um, with Dan
DeVogue, also with our Utah County Fire
Warden, who is an employee of Forestry, Fire, and State Lands.
We reviewed this map, reviewed the idea
of putting— using 7 and 8, including those areas
in the city that are in 7 and 8s on our WUI code map.
And we were all in agreement on that.
So one of the topics of discussion when we were going
through that was those properties that are already developed
and in subdivisions probably aren't as big of a risk.
So we took those subdivided areas out.
There should be no subdivisions in this area.
However, if people— There was. So if we— there
may be Future homes developed up
here, there, here in this area, like in lower Hidden Valley,
they may, when they develop, they may be subject, they would be
subject to these requirements at the time of building permit.
So then that's what the question I had is, so let's say, so you have
like the Horizon subdivision, which is sort of still in the works.
to fall in the WUI, lower Hidden Valley is falling in the WUI,
they're going to have to have sprinklers inside the house? That's a
good question. And I guess Chief Fawcett might be able to answer that. I don't—
there's some aspects of this. There's lower
and higher levels of WUI code that come into play or like
when they kick in. So I don't know if you want to explain that a
little bit to them. Yeah. Specifically on
the sprinkler side, that's in The 2024 WUI Code, which hasn't been adopted yet.
There is a House bill, I believe it's HB 41.
Marcus, I don't know if you have it up, but I think it's HB 41
that's in legislation right now going through rules.
That kind of forces adoption of 2024 WUI Code,
but it carves out sprinklers specifically.
And, you know, we're— They're pretty friendly
towards development up at legislature legislation,
and so I think they're trying to create some
sort of carve-out that it's not completely cost prohibitive to adopt that
code. So that may come into play if
that House bill goes through. The other thing that that House bill does,
from my understanding, is it kind of enforces.
Anything from a risk score of 5 and greater, which would then kind of
force our hand to reconsider our map where it currently sits.
But that's all going through the legislative process
currently. So specifically to sprinklers,
I don't believe it's in the 2006 WUI code.
2024, I believe it's in there, but they're trying to
provide carve-outs for that. Does that answer it?
Very prohibitive to have sprinklers, especially lower Hidden Valley,
and the types of homes that would be going in there, it'd be so prohibitive
to— cost prohibitive to do that. But I just— yeah,
that was my question. Yeah, and I believe most of the sprinklers
is not internal sprinklers, it's exterior or
a capability of water features on the exterior of the structure, not necessarily the
interior. Because once Once you get fire,
especially brush fire, inside of a house,
we can't fight it anyway. And so that's one of
the things is generally it's on an exterior type
of feature, some sort of waterscape, some sort of sprinkler
system exterior, not necessarily interior.
So— That was my question is let's
suppose that an area Once a trail such as the ones that have been identified
are in the WUI map, how do they come out of it? I mean,
once it develops, can they— how are they removed from that?
Is that something the city can do? There's a process where we would
make an application to Fire Forestry State Lands through a particular
process, and then they would send out their warden. Right now,
Garrett Nelson, who's the Utah County Fire Warden,
he would have to come out and get eyes on and do the review for
FFSL. Okay. And then modify the score appropriately.
The smooth score that Brandon showed you, it's, you know,
it's their best guess from GIS layering,
onsite visit, historical recognition. Like, they take a lot of stuff and
mesh that together. But there are some inconsistencies within the map itself,
and that's something that they're trying to work through. But they do have a process,
or at least there— when we met with Garrett, um, there's,
there's a process to, to remove stuff that is identified
as, as a high-risk area. Um, and particularly as we build out
and we have subdivisions or, you know, data centers, or we
have large areas where basically we, we've scraped down to, to dirt,
um, those will no longer fall within that high-risk area.
And that process is what we'd have to do. Now, again,
we have control on our side through this process
on identifying that map outside of the
high-risk map that the state has already put out.
So we can kind of identify what has
already been— Developed. Been developed and
already has features in there that, you know, don't make it as
susceptible. But that's something we'll have to look at as well.
So just for clarity for the public and for the councils, it is HB 48
that is— Oh, 48. I apologize. 48 for 2025.
And then this upcoming bill, the one that's running through now, I can't—
I don't remember. I'm pretty sure it's 48. Is it 48? 48 is the one
that's working its way through the legislature right now. Yeah, there's,
there's that one currently that's, that's working its
way. Okay, well, and then if I can
just clarify, it does look like the lower and upper Hidden Valleys, most of
those are not included in the orange area. The Horizon development is,
looks like that hill. And so it's when you're down in those valleys,
most of that's excluded.
Um, yeah, I'm kind of zooming in there. We,
we noticed that a lot of that Hidden Valley area ended up in
like 6, 5 and 6, area 5 and 6. The other
thing too that I didn't mention is we have to review the
WUI map every 3 years to make sure it's the area
that is being mapped is accurate and,
you know, well thought through. And the WUI code tells us we have
to work with guys like Chief Fossum and Garrett Nielsen,
our— the fire wardens. So we
work through them. But we, again, we do have the ability to
control this map much more. We don't get to control the high-risk
map at all. So, Brandon, yeah, question I have for you. So my home got—
my insurance canceled our house last year, and I live in a subdivision.
It was kind of surprising, and I learned about this indexing process that
I don't know if the fire department establishes that locally Do you know how
this will impact that? Will that replace that system,
or will there be kind of 2 systems in place?
There's 2 systems in place.
It's this map right here that we don't control.
Your insurance company can only use the high-risk
WUI data that the Forestry, Fire, and State
Lands maps. So that's not— it's out of our hands.
But yeah, the state kind of dictates that area.
Is there any other questions at this time? I do know this has been— the
league is— it's on their radar. We've talked about it every day. It was on
there today. So we're still trying to— do
they have a support on this one, or— I think it's still pending. Still pending.
And it's one that we work on Every day. I know Brett's been in those
meetings, so. One critical thing that I will say is,
so we've got that bill running through right now, and one line of thinking
is, well, let's just wait till we get that done to finish this
process up, 'cause maybe if they make us map 5s and 6s,
but then let's wait. Well, I don't think we should do that,
and this is why. Because House Bill 48 of 2024
2025 said that we needed to get this done January 1st or December 31st
of 2025. And so, um,
the, the care— what, what they do to the, the hook there is like that
I told you earlier, that they'll pay our fire bill if,
if we work with them on the CWS stuff. Well, part of that is us
having a mapped, uh, WUI, uh, a WUI map,
and, and we don't have So I think it's best that we get
this mapped and then we can come back and amend it if needs be.
And the bill that we're working on this year is the one that has the
carve-outs. So I think if there's nothing
else, we do have a public hearing on this one. So if we're okay,
we're going to go to that. It is 9:44,
and I will open the public hearing and ask Lacey
who's here to speak on that. Not a single person.
Is there anyone here that Seeing
no one, we will close the public hearing at 9:44.
There has been some of that at the state too.
Um, so the public hearing is closed, and I'll bring it back to the council
for any further questions or dialogue on the WUI map.
Councilmember Clark's good. If that's, uh, if there
is no other discussion, then I'm interested in a motion. Mayor, I move that the
city council approve an ordinance of Eagle Mountain City, Utah, amending Eagle Mountain Municipal
Code Chapter 15.95 and adopting the Eagle Mountain City Wildland
Urban Interface Area Map. Second.
Okay, we have a motion by Councilmember Whiting and a second by Councilmember Huish,
and we'll start the vote. I'm going to start down here. Yes.
And Councilmember Clark? Yes. Councilmember Wright? Yes.
Councilmember Whiting? Yes. Okay, and that motion passes.
Yes. The next item is 18A, an ordinance of Eagle Mountain City
repealing various codes with advisory boards
and enacting Chapter 2.80 of the municipal code establishing
Community Services Board, which will also handle the RAP tax.
This is, uh, Miss Natalie has
a presentation here. She made the changes that we asked for.
Oh, and we did talk about this in the work session, and she has made
those changes, which I think council has seen. So,
um, we'll pull those up. Good evening,
Mayor and Council. Um, just to provide context for everyone
listening online and in the room, um,
this new code would create a community services board
that would take on the responsibility of several
of the other boards that we currently have in our code. It would
replace those and kind of have a centralized point for residents
to be able to interact with the city in terms of everything community service related.
So we would have the— this new Community Services Board, and it would take
on, you know, the RAP tax, parks,
recreation, cemetery,
um, I think also like some
like connection to the veterans and the American
Legion. So that would,
yeah, this would be kind of like the one-stop shop so that citizens have
a centralized place to go. They know what meetings to attend if they want to
have their input and they want to be involved. And yeah,
I have— I'm available for any questions if you guys have any additional
questions. Thank you. So we did talk about this, and as it's in front of
you, the changes that we talked about have been made. And so if you're satisfied,
good. I just want to make sure that someone's reaching out to the people
that were appointed to these boards. I know that you've been calling
and talking to different people, but I also, I want to
make sure that this isn't a place that we fall down as a city and
we acknowledge them and thank them for their service because we're just summarily
dismissing them. So yeah, I know at
least any board that has been active or any participant on the boards I've reached
out to, some of them may be reappointed to the
new board. I also know that the recorder's office, I think Stephanie
and yeah, I think they've been reaching out,
right? Are there any That
we know, has that been completed or are there still some
that we have not reached? I think it's mostly done. Mayor, could— I
mean, could we ask, I think Council Member Clark makes an excellent point, something I
hadn't thought of. How about just a thank you card that goes out to those
who are currently serving or whether they've been
able to meet and get together. I just think a thank you card from the
city would be at least that much, right, to recognize
their service. We've historically done even like a plaque,
just like we've done like with Planning Commissioner, City Council, to thank them
for their service and serving on that board. So for sure,
a thank you card. I just want to make sure that
we're legitimately reaching out to them. And if it's something that you can't
do all alone, I volunteer the entire council to help
you. I think— I
think Ben— it's Ben with the Recorder's Office.
Is that a good place to keep it, or do you have an idea?
We could also work with Chaz and Laura as well. So we'll
take care of it. Thank you. Yep. And then we'll need a list
for sure of who's active and which terms
haven't expired, things like that. So— and I'll
get together. I'll have Chaz get us together so that we can, uh,
go through the ones that I've already contacted for sure. So is
there any other discussion on this one? Questions?
No other concerns? Okay.
Mayor, I move to approve an ordinance— tell me
if I'm saying this right— uh, an ordinance of Eagle Mountain City,
Utah, repealing Chapter 2.3,
Parks and Recreation Advisory Board. Chapter 2.4,
Recreation Sports Board. Chapter 2.55,
Cemetery Board. Chapter 2.6,
Military and Veterans Advisory Board. And Chapter 2.7,
Economic and Development Board. And enacting Chapter 2.8 of
the Eagle Mountain Municipal Code to establish a Community Services Board.
Second. Okay, we have a motion by Council Member Huish and
a second by Council Member Wright. Is there any questions or discussion on the motion?
Seeing none, we will start the vote with Council Member Clark.
Yes. Council Member Wright. Yes. Council Member Whiting. Yes. Council Member
Huish. Yes. Okay, that motion passes.
Some of the code, just while we're on this, for council to be aware of,
Marcus, and you can remind me, we're working on changing the appointment terms
to Q1, right? Yes. And so that's something
that we'll see that's kind of part of this. So terms will expire March
31st and start on April 1st?
Yeah, that's, that's what we're working on. And then the
seniors board. also was going to be brought
forward to be in this same section. So just to make you
aware that we are working on it, but that's coming.
Um, legislative priorities update.
Mr. Magnus.
Good evening, Mayor, council members. Tonight we're gonna do an update on the
strategic plan, general plan update. I know the hour's late. It's up to
you if you still wanna hear it or you wanna kick it to the next
meeting. Dealer's choice. We're already here
and dressed up. You might as well tell us. Okay. We do have— Brandon's gonna
give you a really quick update of the strategic
plan, general plan update. And then if you have any other items you wanna add
to the list, we can do that afterwards.
Hi, really quick. So the future land use map, uh,
we brought that to you, uh, just a couple of weeks ago,
and that's, uh, getting tooled up. And, and, uh,
so once that's finished up, we, we will,
um, bring that back to you just for a final yep,
looks good, and then we will start preparing the future
land use map The other chapters,
frankly, most of the general plan's been—
we divided it into 4 sections. We've sent
out 3 sections. And so
the last section's just basically land use map and the implementation
chapter. So most of it's done.
Strategic— the strategic goals, we've talked
about redoing those a If that does happen, we're gonna
end up revising a little bit of the general plan.
But we can work with that. And AI is
very helpful in helping us to— can
help speed that up a little bit. So our goal is to get that
to you here, you know, once you get that strategic
plan— strategic goal update. Thank you. Looking to get
that to you here later, hopefully midsummer,
if not sooner. So that's—
we've sent out a few, a number of those chapters.
If you have any feedback, let us know. We'd love feedback
and just really appreciate the support you've given us.
So Yep.
That's about it. We'll bring another council priority list
item on the next meeting. We only have 13 more days, allegedly,
of season. So we're getting close. And I will— my
brain will function again, hopefully soon.
Yeah. Yes. Yes,
they— all the good bills come out now.
Yeah, right when they suspend the rules and start going crazy.
Yeah. So we'll be busy for the next 13 days dealing with some
of these. And the fire bills are HB 41 and
45. 41 implements the code with
the carve-out for the sprinklers. 45 implements the code, no carve-out
for the sprinklers, and makes it So no city can go below Zone
5. So that's the difference between the 2 bills. 41 has
been— That's what we talked about today. Yeah, 41 has been enrolled.
So unless the governor vetoes, we will be updating
the fire codes with the carve-out for the fire sprinklers.
Okay, other legislative priorities? You're good unless
there's any other questions. I just wanted to make sure that anything that Evan's tracking
that we're working on. I do want to bring up, if while
you're thinking about it, if there's anything, uh, HB 184. You saw the League sent
just now action alert to strongly oppose this.
Uh, I've reached out earlier this afternoon to Stephanie
specifically, and she said it's dead in committee,
but it can always get on life support and come back. Is that sub 1
or sub 2? This is sub 3. Sub 3. Yes. Yeah,
and they typically don't issue those unless something— a vote is imminent.
Yeah, so this— yeah, the action alert
at least. And it— so I think I've only talked to Stephanie
today. That's the only one I've had time. I don't know if we need to
reach out to Heidi and Emily or Bramer, um, and make
sure that we react, because this one will preempt city's authority. One of
the things in here is if we don't act within 30 days,
deemed approved on subdivisions. So that's
a little scary, a little bit of an overreach. So I
might encourage everybody to reach
out to our people and tell them it's— I don't
think it has any traction. Anything else? I actually have a question about that
specific thing. Is there any way that we could push kind of
like a carve-out or an exception for cities that issue
over X amount of building permits a year or have X amount of
vested units? Because I see— We need a bill sponsor to do it.
Like, I see, is it coming up in committee? Has anyone
pitched that? It's dead in committee right now. And so what I would tell you
is I don't want to make a carve-out. I want to kill it. I think
you should kill it too. the league because it's not good for any city,
let alone us. If it was to get
traction, I think that would be a bare minimum. But for right now, I think
the stance is just— Kill it. Yeah, this is a bad bill.
Mayor, so I was asked about that bill tonight. It has
a hearing tomorrow at 4 o'clock. It is back on.
That's why we got the answer. It is back on agenda tomorrow at 4 o'clock.
So it was dead at 3 o'clock and it's got— welcome to the system.
Right. So 184 had been held in committee. There's a sub
2 and a sub 3 out, and it is on the agenda tomorrow
at 4 o'clock. I did bring this, and I don't know if you guys got
it, but I brought this back earlier. It tells kind of the— I think I
gave them to these guys, but you guys are welcome to that.
It's kind of the rundown. Terrible bill.
Sorry, Evan, I keep looking over there. Nothing? No more?
Okay, um, any other
legislative priorities from the body? Okay,
we'll go on to the liaison reports and council mayor
business. Um,
is there anything, or I can start here? Go ahead. No liaison.
I filled in for you at the seniors this month, and they have a lot
going on. And I think you and I spoke, but I can't even remember what
it was. Yeah, yep, you've got that.
Did you guys see the dance, youth dance? How awesome was that? I was
there. I wanted to be there, I couldn't be there. But yeah, seeing some of
the social media footage, it was awesome. Lots of attendance, it looked like.
I'm gonna be meeting with the library board tomorrow night, so I'll have an
update on that afterwards.
Nothing? Council Clerk, you good? Great.
Okay, um,
any other— let's see, the last thing is,
is there anything on the communication items or
go to the discussion? Um, the only thing
I wanted to bring up is we were talking about, um,
the desire to have an additional retreat Prior to April,
is there a desire, and when does the council want
to look towards doing that?
For this next retreat, is this like
an all hands on deck staff one, or could this be bare bones and
do it like on a Saturday morning so that
it depends on the agenda items? And we've got four or five different things,
and maybe we tackle the most pressing. And then save the
rest for St. George. I, I just,
I'm very cognizant of the staff time,
but I also get that we do more as a city council than most
cities do in an entire year. And sometimes we're asked
to take off so much time from work, it may be good for us to
do a Saturday morning or something like that so that it
doesn't take more time off of We
can look at some dates and see staff-wise
and then have Lara— Maybe I'll send out a Doodle poll to everybody and—
That would work. That sounds great. And then we'll see if we can't get something
here shortly. And we can do an evening. We can
kind of tackle these a little bit at a time, I think. A couple hours
of time would be great. The last item is a discussion
on the discussion on the annual budget. And I'm sorry this got pushed
clear to the end, but I
think we're gonna get a— we're in the beginning of the budget cycle, so maybe
a little higher level view of the—
And maybe while Kimberly's coming up, the reason that— see,
we typically have historically have met on the off
weeks between 3 and 5 before Planning Commission,
but we know it's been impactful on elected leaders and your schedules and
whatnot. So we were trying to do it the first hour of your work meetings,
but our work meetings have been so, uh,
jam-packed that it's now pushed to the end of the meeting,
and here we are. So thank you, Kimberly. So I,
I did have some conversation. I'll let you weigh in too, but I was just
going to say, I mean, I, I I liked how 3 to 5 worked on
off Tuesdays personally. I know it's a sacrifice,
but it's also a dedicated time with a hard stop. And I think 2 hours
is about all I can take of budget discussions in
any one sitting. And so I really like how
that functioned, Kimberly. I realize that that may not work for everyone,
but I really like how that works. I think that's where,
again tonight, what part of the hope is, is it's more about determining
what is beneficial to the council. Okay, so we don't want to have meetings
just to have meetings. We want to make sure that, you know, like,
I'm sure that— So,
Debbie,
I lost my mic. And Ben, I had some conversation based on that,
and I think the council is open to 3 to 5,
as mentioned. On the off weeks, is it once a month or twice
a month? It's just once a month. So is it the 2nd Tuesday
or 3rd— sorry, 4th Tuesday? So we did it in between the 1st and 3rd
council meetings, so it would have been the 2nd Tuesday, I think. So it's the
2nd Tuesday from 3 to 5. We have council meeting, then we'd have a budget
meeting, then we'd have council meeting, then we'd have nothing. So what's that gonna give
us, 3 meetings before— Between now and May. So it will only give
you Actually, 2. So you're gonna get March and April,
and then you're gonna get the tentative budget in May. So in regards to
that too, so the tentative budget, I just wanna make sure,
because it is one of those items that feels a little bit intimidating,
because what happens on, we're mandated to provide to the
council the first meeting in May a tentative budget. But when that
tentative budget is being turned over to the council, You basically
have to, you are accepting it, and that's it. But what that means is
you're accepting the fact that administration provided you with the
tentative budget as required by law. And then that is when the beginning process
takes place for the council to be able to kind
of dig through it, make any changes, have meetings, as much as you want,
and then we have to have an adopted budget by the end of June,
so we, and have our public hearings and things like that. Okay.
I like to try to make sure we're touching on things as we come along,
because the last thing we want is for you to get a budget in May
that then has to be torn apart, or that doesn't feel like it's meeting the
objectives and the vision of the council and what we want to do. So that
was the— that's the purpose between kind of having
these budget meetings, is we just kind of bite off chunks of some
of these pieces, and we'll cover operations and personnel and we'll have a meeting
where we talk about capital and things like that. And it's to try to make
sure that we continue in the direction that the council is expecting for
the upcoming year. So to be clear, let's go back on dates because right now
we're planning on the personnel part on March 5th with our
other, the special meeting, right? That's what we talked about?
I think we— Isn't March 5th just the
public hearing or? Yeah. Yeah, because we didn't, we weren't able to have the other
meeting and it does have to do with finance, I was gonna do both.
And I thought we talked about that. So if we do March 5th, 'cause if
we come in anyway, the public hearing should be pretty light. That's a Thursday?
Yeah, it's a Thursday. Yeah, but that's— So we're gonna—
That public hearing is the $230 million thing.
And with that type of public hearing, we have to let it go until they're
done, right, Marcus? That's the one where like they
could filibuster forever. When I say filibuster, 3 minutes at a time,
different people. Right. I mean, depending on how many
people show up, we would have to let all of them speak.
But that's not any different than how we would do any public hearing. Mayor just
jinxed us by saying it was going to be light. Well, we have a meeting
on the 3rd, and then we're going to come back on the 5th and do
it. What week is that? Thursday. It's on a Thursday.
And if we plan— otherwise, we're not going to see her until
when? So then you're— then we're looking at April,
right? So yeah, so it makes sense to me to at least schedule it,
to notice it, and to conduct it that way if there's time to do it.
If we find that we're running 6 hours in a public hearing,
I mean, at some point in time the mayor can call that and say we're
just gonna— we're gonna postpone that and dismiss you, and we'll just finish up the
public hearing. So I think we'll plan the 5th on a Thursday,
and that will be right after the public hearing, which I think is scheduled for
5 o'clock. 5:30, you're right, 5:30.
Then we'll come, the second Tuesday of
April would be the next meeting and then it's May. So those are
the 2 meetings that we're looking for right now. Is that agreeable?
And it'll be 3 to 5 on the second Tuesday of April. Is that gonna
be enough? That's my question because— April 14th.
14th, almost tax day. The question is, that is
not for you. Well, Kimberly's good all the way through. If you want
to start, I'll be here in May. And I haven't— I haven't— I mean,
I obviously haven't participated in this with Councilmember Huish or with Councilmember
Whiting. I don't know how engaged they're going to be. I know how Councilmember
Wood's going to be engaged. He's going to engage. And Councilmember Clark always engages.
So I'm counting on that. Okay. And sometimes I can't
shut up. So But, but I think the issue that I
have is, is it going to be enough? And I, I would rather
overplan and finish it up early where
we can release you in May and you don't have to see us in May
and June, rather than feel like, oh my gosh, we're having to adopt this
and it's still not where we want it to be. And you guys haven't been
through that process. Should we wait till you go through it? Should we add a
3 to 5 both on the the 2nd and the 4th weeks. I was just
gonna say the 28th. That's when I'm thinking would work best. So let's get through
it early and let's terminate it early if we can. So the 28th of April
would be the 2nd Tuesday, or sorry, the 4th Tuesday, the 2nd meeting.
That's my birthday. No, I've been here on my birthday a lot.
We'll bring you a cake. So if you want,
we can pencil it in if we need it, if that's— I am available.
We usually celebrate birthdays here, Zach. You don't know that yet.
So the 28th of April, if you want to pencil it in, would that be—
that would be a 3 to 5 as well.
And then— Can we get calendar invites from this? Like from— Yeah.
Terrence has got us. He'll take care of us. Okay. The 14th,
the 28th. And then let's see how many we need. So the 5th,
the 14th, and the 28th are our 3 budget meetings prior to the
tentative budget and the public hearings, which will happen in June.
Correct, and then in May, we can continue to have more meetings.
So again, that's when we'll have the draft
tentative budget that will also come. Last year was the first year we kind of
tried to have the full book available that provided more information
to kind of explain the whys behind everything that we were doing. But as we
dig into that, that is where we can as we're going
through it. If you have specific questions more on projects or
more on if there is program changes, then we,
again, once the tentative budget comes out, we're focusing specifically
on council-driven initiatives
of what do you want to know more about or have questions or to
make sure is clear before we move forward. Thank you.
Okay, those are on the calendar. And then for today's
discussion, it was, uh, it's not personnel. Yep, so that's all we're going
to cover tonight because it is, uh, 10 o'clock and,
um, you've covered enough. It's about— yep, it's covered enough. We'll make sure that
we, um— so what the change is, because you're going to give us some dedicated
time, that is what will make this work. It does make it really hard
Either if we're going to present, we want to be able to give you and
have the time. It's not just about us providing information. It's really important that we're
getting the dialogue and that the council feels comfortable
with what the strategic goals and objectives are and what we're trying to accomplish.
So if we can have these dedicated meetings instead of trying to smash
it into the end, we will make sure that that time is utilized well and
to the best of it. And then my final note is I was so excited
today. It's only happened 2 times in my 29-year career
that people have talked and commented during the public hearings for budget
amendments, so, or anything related to budget or finance. And I love—
I mean, it's not a negative thing. It's that people are engaged and they have
something to say. So tonight was a great night for Eagle Mountain City. I'm going
to say something to you, and I want you to hear this loud and clear.
Having participated in this process now for 4 years,
this being my 5th, I really appreciate the way that you have kind
of morphed it. It's highly effective, it's very
engaging, and I feel as a council member that
I'm heard, that the priorities that I'm advocating for allows me an opportunity
to engage with my council member compadres. I don't
know what I call you guys. Colleagues. Colleagues. I couldn't think of the right
word. And that we together come to some decisions about what
our priorities are and how we're going to achieve them with the budget. So I,
I think it's the best process. You've, you've developed it
into the very best process that I've participated in, and I'm grateful for that.
And I hate to see that get modified. That's why I'm advocating for the time
that you're asking for.
Okay, that's a discussion item only, and I see Kimberly saying
dropping the mic. So unless there's any other business,
are you open to a motion? Motion to adjourn.
Second. Okay, we got a motion from Councilmember Clark, a second from Councilmember
Whiting, and we'll start the vote. All in favor?
Aye. Any opposed? Motion passes,
and we are adjourned at 10:11 PM.